Guten Morgen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 252 vom 5.Mai 2018.
Der wöchentliche unaufgeregte Rand 500 buddhistischen.
Total unaufgeregt na ist ja auch nichts oder, irgendwas zum Aufregen heute ganz entspannt.
009 noch nicht noch nicht noch nicht wir sind gekommen ja noch erstmal ist ja freundliches Vorgeplänkel dann kommt Feedback und dann dann dann regen wir uns langsamer auf.
Aber ja Psycho genau namens noch psychologische Beratung dazugeholt.
Ja wir haben einen Sendungs Gast und zwar ich habe gerade schon Vorgespräch gesagt und wo man sich dann auch denkst du wir haben tatsächlich geschafft so viele Sendung zu machen ohne dich da einmal ein zu langsam mich ein bisschen gewundert Stephan Urbach.
Wie stellt man dich wie stellt man sich vor Tausendsassa der der des Aktivismus viele Autor Autor muss mein Auto als Verleger.
Zwischendurch jetzt Verleger noch neu consultant.
Biografie Schreiber Halter.
Das Mastermind hinter Tims SKR04 buchhaltungs Konzept.
Es tut mir leid ich habe mich dafür nicht entschuldigen.
Also wer die Freakshow hört Stefan hat das alles verbrochen.
Pfeffer brauchen ja Diana Montana Consultant ein Verleger und irgendwie Aktivisten Rentner ich Rente nur noch ins Ausland nur noch aber ich mache nicht mehr so viel ja ich als Rentner.
Das ist gut das will ich auch mal wenn ich groß bin.
Vergangenheit dunkle Vergangenheit zweite Vergangenheit.
Ja hatte ich bei Orange tut mir leid war eine gute Idee gewesen ist am Ende wissen wir ja alle.
Musst du dich nicht verstehen was ja nicht allein.
Das ist richtig.
Ja und wir freuen uns wir freuen uns Dich jetzt an zwei Themen die wir mit dir besprechen deswegen werden wir nicht alles was gerade aktuelles Thema ist behandeln dass wir waren zeitnah die nächste Sendung da wären wir dann.
Auch auf die anderen auf die weniger wichtigen kleineren Themen eingehen.
Dann haben wir noch eine kleine ich glaube das kann man glaube ich sogar schon im Prolog schon machen oder warten wir damit auf die Termine.
Nee das war jetzt.
Mama jetzt die Gulag gulaschprogrammiernacht finity.
Wochenende in.
Was ist nicht ob wir da noch willkommen sind das war's.
Aber ist doch passend zu Marx ja liebe Leute 200 Jahre Marx Skoda Kombi.
Oh weia.
Nächstes Wochenende ist gulaschprogrammiernacht das in den Termin ja schon angekündigt das größte Chaos Event glaube ich inzwischen.
Ist das nicht so was wäre.
Ich weiß nicht mehr bin über.
Kempis was heißt das zweitgrößte.
Pampers 2 Größe.
Aber die gulaschprogrammiernacht rockt regelmäßig irgendwie über 1000.
Mittlerweile über 1000 ja.
Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht so sicher wie sehr die anderen Veranstaltung alle angeschwollen sind so immer im CD und so weiter da ist ja noch so.
Ja okay dass alle die sagen dass die die Entropia der feine Entropia oder der CCC Erfa in Karlsruhe nennt ja den Kongress immer die Winter GPS.
Ja das ist richtig ja.
Ja es hat ihn noch nie so richtig ansetzt Bewusstsein gemangelt.
Adresse Wasserwaage für dich lernte aufgrund zu schönes Event am im ZKM Zentrum für Kultur und Medien Kunst und Medien in Karlsruhe.
Ja und Hochschule für Medien nebendran deckt an also beides zusammen.
Und Hochschule genau also da und.
Hoffe Schönwiese.
Auf der schönen Wiese vom.
Ja Wunder vom Generalbundesanwalt.
General Generalbundesanwalts her.
Das war ja da sind Wiesel aber wo das war so schön.
Genau man kann da kann man sitzt quasi direkt beim Generalbundesanwalt und kann versuchen also man sollte jetzt nicht mit der Drohne über also das geht dann gibt's die gucken.
Also auch gar nicht so gut ist da sitzen und Bier zu trinken also für ein paar Jahren war das nicht rippitsch interessiert Polizeiautos und es war sehr anstrengend alles.
Es ist.
Prominente Nachbarschaft.
Es ist genau eine prominente Nachbarschaft sehr schönes Event und.
Wir freuen uns euch mitteilen zu dürfen dass unsere Einreichung dort angenommen wurde und dass wir dort am Freitagabend die LMP 253.
Machen werden vor Publikum DGPM ist ja eine kostenlose Veranstaltung man könnte also sagen die LMP 253 bei der GPM wird sowas wie die LMP 256 für Schwaben.
Ich habe geguckt das ist in Schwaben.
Na ich in Berlin hast du mittlerweile auch genug Schwaben also von daher.
Na ja also dass die beiden Veranstaltung Folgen jetzt aufeinander aber sind nicht miteinander zu verwechseln wir werden einfach ne ganz normale Sendung machen wie wir sonst auch machen ja natürlich.
Logbuch Netzpolitik 56 wir schon mehrfach angedeutet wird ein etwas größerer Aufriss ist und noch mit anderen Elementen daher kommen die.
Es dort Inkasso nicht geben wird trotz alledem mit der also auf der gps seid dann könnt ihr gerne.
Dazu kommen das ist jetzt Gruppe auf den Freitag taxiert der genauer Zeitraum kann sich noch erinnern wie das so mit Fahrplänen so ist am ja und wer ohnehin dahin kommen wollte.
Könnte dann sozusagen auch uns noch mal kurz lauschen oder die Hand schütteln oder was auch immer.
Handschellen Suzuki wir sind dann glaube ich auch die,
am Samstagabend werden Arne Bense und ich noch ein bisschen Schunkelmusik auflegen aber nur eine einstündige Slot ich glaube um 0:30 Uhr oder so also.
Bist schon so eine Exit-Strategie von dir nennt man Politik nicht so läuft dann dann wirst du einfach DJ.
Schunkelmusik mal schauen ob das so.
Was gibt's schöneres als im hohen Alter solchen Veranstaltungen.
Beim easterhegg habe ich ja mit David zusammen aufgelegt und also ich war ja ich habe ja vor wie der größte das wird ja super funktioniert ich habe dann nachher noch mal die Aufzeichnung angehört also da glaube ich da habe ich auf jeden Fall noch,
Wachstumspotenzial die Musik einmal gelaufen ist war das gut die Übergänge.
Wann spüre ich.
War das so mit Vinyl oder solltest Du vielleicht auf Traktor umsteigen damit sich das automatisch mixed.
Mit Traktor ich dachte eigentlich das wäre idiotensicher aber ich müsste dann noch mal so hätte da noch mal so ein paar Wünsche das könnte man noch ein bisschen mehr automatisieren.
Ich kann mich das auch nicht alleine zu machen deswegen beim.
Herberge der neben mit Anne Bense der ja bei uns sehr bekannt ist das ist der eine der immer wieder.
Immer wieder schöne Lieder macht Cyber Cyber gemacht hat damit gings los wenn regelmäßig beim Kongress mal was vertont und regelmäßig bei uns auch mal.
Zu Streit mit dem freue ich mich auf jeden Fall mit ihm Aufzügen wird wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich sag auflegen mal gucken was er da noch auflegen.
Deine.
So lass uns um Feedback kommen.
Wir haben relativ viel Feedback bekommen zur Bundesdatenschutzgesetz dsgvo und so weiter.
Oder wurde korrekt erkannt dass wir da natürlich nicht die klügsten sind Anja Müller sagt ich bin kein Jurist aber wenn ich das neue BDSG an,
sehe gibt es dort eine ähnliche Öffnungsklausel wie in Österreich gegen Behörden und sonstige öffentliche Stellen im Sinne des paragraph 21 in keine Geldbußen verhängt,
und öffentliche Stellen des Bundes sind die Behörden die Organe der Rechtspflege und andere öffentlich recht,
ich organisierte Einrichtung des Bundes der bundesunmittelbaren Körperschaften Anstalten und Stiftungen öffentlichen Rechts sowie deren Vereinigung ungeachtet ihrer Rechtsform.
Wir werden das Thema dsgvo in einer der künftigen Sendungen mit jemanden besprechen der sich damit ganz gut auskennt.
Vielmehr sage ich da glaube ich garnicht zu aber Richert korrigiert auch das muss als Korrektur noch mit rein sicher korrigiert obwohl die dsgvo.
Verordnung heißt hat sie einen Nazi teilweise einen richtigen Charakter Mitgliedstaaten haben Umsetzung Spielraum z.b. das Geldbußen für öffentliche Stellen betrifft.
Zu Änderung bei der Strafbarkeit von Behörden die war schon von der alten groko ausgeschlossen worden jetzt ist neu dass sie unabhängig von der Organisationsform gilt nur.
Nur weil es keine Strafen gibt heißt das ja nicht automatisch rechtsfreier Raum den Datenschutzbehörde das trotzdem noch Anordnungen zu weitergeben.
Also auch hier wieder sehr viel mehr Detail als wir hier verstanden haben kann er noch mal darauf verweisen.
Dass wir das Thema in einer zukünftigen Sendung noch mehr besprechen werden.
Genau welcher Tag noch vor allem hier in Österreich wird der Datenschutz auch gerne verwendet um Informationen nicht preisgeben zu müssen die vielleicht im.
Öffentlichen Interesse liegen und wenn ein Journalist weniger Angst vor den hohen Strafen hat muss das nicht nur schlecht sein also da geht der Bezug auf die den dsgvo Schutz für.
Im im Bereich Journalisten dass da im gesagt wird da ist natürlich da wird also Informationsfreiheit und öffentliches Interesse in einer Abwägung.
Gezogen und das muss nicht immer schlecht sein ist auch ein wichtiger. Weil wir das letzte Mal auch noch relativ kritisch gesehen haben.
Damit wären wir bei unserem ersten Thema und bei der LMP2 100 hatten wir ja den Rayk anders zu Gast.
Und der Youtuber der fröhlich weiter und hat dann auch mit.
Der kooperative Berlin und zum Team investigativer Journalisten quasi jetzt im letzten Jahr so im vergangenen anderthalb Jahren oder ein Jahr eine Doku,
produziert mit dem Namen lösch dich wie sich der Held im Netz organisiert.
Haben wir in den in den Ort verlinkt kann ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen weil die sich die haben sich mit diesem conquista germanika Germania eine Germania.
Germania.
Reconquista Germania also dieser dieser discord Plattform wo sich ja Hater.
Rechte Hater im Netz irgendwie organisieren die sich da irgendwie eine.
Germanica heiße.
Germanica Reconquista germanica dann die sich ein bisschen mit auseinandergesetzt haben sich da rein.
Da da auch in also mit eingebracht und die Türen ja dann irgendwelche Vorstellungsgespräche umlackieren wie militärische Ränge zu vergeben.
Und dann verabreden die sich da oben irgendwie unter YouTube kommen unter YouTube Videos irgendwelche hasskommentare zu schreiben und meinen damit würden Sie jetzt irgendwie was,
Sensitivität der Aufklärung Vorschub leisten.
Sehr interessant da mal Einblicke zu bekommen wieso eine organisierte Idiotie funktioniert Höhepunkt haben sich damit irgendwie zwei so wirklich relativ.
Am Figuren unterhalten die Breitband den Interview zu geben.
Merkst du auch wirklich dass sie jetzt nie so einen großen theoretischen Unterbau haben weil jetzt auch nicht weil es ja auch nicht von auszugehen aber ist auch sehr schön diese beiden Deppen da noch mal zusehen wie sie irgendwie so.
Wir wirklich wieso wieso wieso Grundschule in Sinzig Rhein Grill das ist wirklich interessant da mal am lebenden Objekt zu studieren weiterer Höhepunkt Martin Sellner.
Dieser Schwachmat hat von der idiot Ehren Bewegung.
Der dann da irgendwie der ist ja jetzt ja nicht ganz so doof seine Anhänger sind halt ein bisschen doof.
Schwierig.
Wieder also was der dann der Vater sind also ganz normale mit Toten im Infokrieg unter die Zielseite.
Was du hast du hast gott hat dir das Leben geschenkt und du verbringst es irgendwie im Infokrieg in den Kommentarspalten also das ist wirklich.
Ich finde das wirklich so die tut mir so leid ja und ich habe jetzt.
Ich habe da jetzt vor einiger Zeit mal einen Vortrag zugehalten gut drauf trotz Social Media.
Die Kunst des Rollens beim Zündfunk netzkongress ist ein paar Jahre her und da habe ich so ein bisschen,
dann weiß ich nicht ob da auf diese Reconquista germanica,
da nur das schon Internet hatten oder oder ob die da schon dran hatten und kleine halbstündiger Vortrag wo ich ein bisschen die Regeln dieses Spiels,
betreuen und und hating erkläre und in den letzten Wochen.
Habe ich mir da offenbar auch so ein paar von diesen von diesem selbsternannten konfiskatorische eingetreten ich zitiere Prana kahle.
Interessant wie ein Parasit der Halbschuh alt ist wie ich mir erklärt was Trollen ist Linus Neumann zu viel reedukation abbekommen CCC ist sowas von unterwandert und verseucht da ist Arbeit in eine Gulag wie ein sonntags,
Spaziergang dagegen Kranke Bastarde wie Neumann gehören in eine geschlossene... Ja das ist schön das dass wir.
Ich freue mich so richtig dass diese Leute ist noch nicht mal verstehen dass dieser Vortrag davon handelt was sie für Idioten sind und sie dann so direkt noch so Belegexemplare.
Von ihrer ascunse unter mein Kommentar schreiben insofern danke ich den da auch herzlich empfehle meinen eigenen Vortrag noch mal und vor allem die Kommentare da drunter die nicht alle mit einem.
Herzchen versehen habe weil.
Was sie ärgert.
Weil ich weil ich mich da wirklich drüber gefreut habe.
Ich freue mich wirklich darüber dass ich ologe in was für ein Abschaum ja doch ich finde das super weil die hat wirklich.
Das q.e.d. sind unter meinen unter meinem Vortrag über über ihre über ihre EDP.
Ja aber was habt ihr die Doku geschaut.
Ich habe geschaut ja.
Und was bringt wie fandet ihr sie.
Ja aber ich fand sie prinzipiell gut es wird schon besser als ob die beiden.
Mein Leben in Objekte den sie gesprochen haben und die Reconquista zusammen gehören würden das tun sie aber überhaupt nicht dass es wichtig also das sind anders ist anders schlechte Menschen.
Ja das ist alles andere Trolle ja.
Bitte auch kannst ja auch so an die also die sind nicht Reconquista germanica Tasche aus das einfach nur so schlechte Menschen.
Das einfach nur so Hobby Fahrschule die ist halt jetzt lustig finden außer mit diesen Rechten ich war kein wie man das denn soll.
Nativen die Sinti und diesen Bildern zu spielen.
Gerade hat er denn dieses Hakenkreuz Shirt HKN krz und dann.
Und dann so blöd tun und Vechta.
Ja ach echt ja und so nein und wir sind ja gar nicht rechts und so und vielleicht sind sie sitzt irgendwie tief in ihrem Herzen auch nicht aber sie.
Verhalten sich halt einerseits so und gehender super in dem den ganzen Film auf total auf dem Leim.
Und Tragen natürlich damit auch dazu bei dass das eben auch weiter verharmlost wird und machten generell so den Eindruck als ob die eigentlich von ihrem.
Und da nicht so richtig verstehen und fühlen sich einfach unglaublich geil da drin so toll zu sein.
Ja ich bin halt ich finde keine Trolle.
Sind halt keine Trolle es gibt einen entscheidenden Unterschied zwischen dem Troll und einem Idioten nicht jeder Idiot hat automatisch das Qualitätsprädikat Troll.
Michael anrufen.
Ja bei mir läuft das ja nicht unter Qualitätsprädikat aber.
Ich finde mit meinem Schriftrolle los wenn für Menschen die einfach andere Leute fertig machen und schaden wollen bis es also ich finde es irgendwie.
Ja hast einen schöneren Begriff am Start.
Ja kackbratzen a********** ich habe da eine Liste zur Not also für mich jetzt nicht unbedingt dann findest ein.
Ja gut das ist das ja nein etablierten Terminal.
Achso ja Krankenhaus und jetzt ziemlich gut ein.
Also mein etablierter turn für solche Leute ist ehrlichgesagt arme Sau.
Ja das auch aber ich habe kein Mitleid mehr mit denen also so nach den Jahren ist es einfach vorbei.
Mitleid habe ich jetzt auch über.
Deswegen darf man sein ist mir bald auch egal mittlerweile ne dafür habe ich zu viele Leute gesehen und wegen gelitten haben und macht einfach so dass.
Ja das ist das ist natürlich der entscheidende. Das wird ja auch in dieser Dokkum bisschen angesprochen darf das eben nicht immer.
Auf Menschen trifft die aus Erfahrung oder aus Reflektionsvermögen in diesen Bereichen dickes Fell haben und darüber lachen können ich kann jetzt darüber lachen wenn ich von diesen Leuten beschimpft werde.
Ich finde das wirklich lustig mit mich freut dass ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen dass das.
Wenn du nicht in einer privilegierten Position bist wie ich wenn du immer bis kombinierten Situation bist.
Es ist alles nicht lustig.
Wenn du in der anderen Lebenssituation bist wenn du vor allem vielleicht auch nicht eine Person bis die mit öffentliche Auseinandersetzung jetzt ein bisschen erfahrener ist das dass dich sehr schwer treffen kann.
Und das haben wir ja viel erlebt gerade wie auch mit Frauen umgegangen wird was die sich da geben müssen da ist das auch nicht mehr witzig kann ich auch verstehen dass das was den widerfährt nicht mehr an sein.
Untis Untis und deswegen will ich dass wir diesen Brief tolle für solche Leute loswerden einfach weil das ist auch verharmlost alleine das ist nämlich der brückentroll sein Wegezoll haben will das halt machen handfest schlechter Mensch.
Und wie findet er das darüber dass darüber mal so aufgeklärt also ich finde das z.b. dass sie ihre Shitstorms da orchestrieren und sich dazu verabreden und da irgendwie das finde ich schon.
Nee das ist habe ich eigentlich irgendwie also ich habe es jetzt nicht so merkwürdig ich meine ich habe irgendwie jetzt in den letzten Jahren viel Antifa Arbeit gemacht habe und ich weiß auch so aus dem Mailbox zehn Zeiten,
da gab es Nazi Mailbox multischuss gleiche gemacht haben das ist einfach jetzt nur die gleichen Techniken mit neuer mit neuen Werkzeugen.
Okay aber ich find's richtig über diese Techniken mal Aufzug.
Also ja ja also das irgendwie dass sie sich zusammenrotten dass sie sich verletzen und und das machen ja auch irgendwie das dass sie die die direkten mögen top-down Strukturen.
Total gut drauf klar was ist auch verstehen einfach halten das ist irgendwie so irgendwie bei linken gucken die er so ein bisschen diffuser sind das ist ja nicht für die,
das hast du keinen Platz drinne keinen festen das ist um dieses,
daunting sowie ein planen und führen auch das ist total super das haben wir schon seit Jahren also auch die 90er schon gesehen hat mir die irgendwie die Glatzen nicht richtig auf der Straße die irgendwie,
Möbel gemacht haben die Leute dahinter waren meistens dann die älteren Menschen dahinter die eigentlich sind die Gedanken Arbeiter Intergem,
na das ist heute noch genauso und es ist nur heute noch viel viel zugänglicher,
also so ein discord Server ist halt einfacher zu wenig als damals Mailbox und doch einfach zu wenig als irgendwie das Passwort Treffen am Hauptbahnhof.
Ne das heißt das viel mehr Menschen Zugang sie sich die sich damit infizieren können mitmachen kann und das ist eigentlich das neue gefährliche dabei es ist halt einfacher mitzumachen diesen ganzen rechten.
Sumpf.
Also noch vorher und zu mal auch leider die das selber mit zu verdanken leider die halt eben die Wortwahl eine ist die einzig anderen kann ich bin ich rechts.
Na so fit um es geht um Remigration blablabla das ist ja das.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr gerade bei der AFD bei anderen rechten Gruppierungen dass sie es schaffen ihre Sprache zu normalisieren.
Und das ist um das Unterhalt mehr so sein da steht und dann irgendwie nicht in die in die Kamera labert das ist ein Relegation mit mir sie alles irgendwie ja alles wollen frei leben aber bitte bei sich und,
das ist sehr komplex und halt riesig ein ich hasse, die ganzen vegan Nazi Hipster dazu die in ihre Kochvideos machen.
Nazi.
Ja Leute es gibt es gibt ein YouTube Kanal mit veganen Nazi Hipster die die kochen mit Sturmhauben auf und haben mit der Welt da stehen.
Ist nicht dein Ernst hat nenne sich auch so oder nimmst du sie so.
Ich nehme jetzt hören wie die heißen,
auch eine kleine diese dieser diesen Nazi Hipster mit dem Krümelmonster Pullover der aber irgendwie das ist ein kleiner schmächtiger Typ auch wenn das Maul aufmachen dann nur braune Scheiße raus im großen Schwall total nett aus.
Das ist also das kann also auch alles mit in die Flex mit drei nein das darf man sich in die Lippe Trachten und das ist Nasus Fähigkeiten die anguckst irgendwie jetzt Wahrnehmung gewesen am ersten Mal auf Nazis leider.
Das Amphitheater zwischen studiert und habe irgendwie so ein sososo Röhrenjeans an also,
so du bist ein Jutebeutel shinshin Hakenkreuz drauf oder so jetzt mal 1 nehmen Göring Bild drauf gedruckt siebdruck.
Ich fahre aber also.
Mann schaut sich das jetzt an ich war ja jetzt irgendwie klar dass wenn man sich jetzt in DDD,
anschaut wie politische Bewegungen agieren sich wandeln und auch Zulauf bekommen ne also es war,
eigentlich schon klar so soll ich mit der linke Teil hat jetzt mit sowas wie Paint Hedonistische Internationale Zentrum für politische Schönheit in den letzten 10 Jahren gut in Richtung,
Kommunikationsguerilla noch mal wieder gearbeitet ist nicht das erste Mal dass das geschieht ganzer 80er Jahren und 70er Jahren immer noch immer.
60er Jahre Fritz Teufel was auch immer alles ne du hast da wurde also.
Wurden politische Strategie aufgezeigt und verfolgt und,
die sind sexy geworden und die haben Anklang gefunden war relativ klar dass irgendwann einmal ein rechter versucht das nachzumachen ich bin eigentlich immer noch erleichtert die schlecht diese identitäre Bewegung dabei ist also die Aktion sind halt.
Nicht besonders witzig,
nicht besonders kreativ da ist noch Luft nach oben aber das sieht sehr das achte auf dieser Sellner in dieser Doku ja entscheidend ist dass es wie reagiert auf Twitter und das oder auf Facebook,
das kriegen sie jetzt ganz gut hin das kann man ja auch lernen kann man im uns auch die letzte Rückschau noch mal empfehlen wo er Sebastian Jarosch zu Gast war und da auch ein bisschen drüber gesprochen hat das dass das eben auch ein Handwerk ist.
In diesen sozialen Medien irgendwie erfolgreich zu sein und sich aufzubauen und das machen die jetzt und ich finde das.
Interessant aber ich würde ihn jetzt bitte jetzt auch nicht schockierend.
Der Depp Depp das was gibt es geht um das was sie denken und das ist halt Stoß.
Und den diesen diese Diskussion kann man glaube ich führen unabhängig davon ob die ob es den jetzt gelingt eine coole Aktion zu machen oder nicht in meiner ich habe von denen noch keine coole Aktion gesehen sei mal bisschen schwach und die sind auch,
immer noch so ein bisschen ich meine jetzt gerade in sehr schöne Aktion ja Antifa Wien den wir angefangen Nazis abschieben.
Wäsche.
Dann stehen A5 zu handeln von der von den Idioten und dann stehen irgendwie 20 Leute drum herum und haben ihre Regenschirme offen um.
Finde ich finde eine schöne Aktion und so geht das halt immer weiter und aber.
Das wird in die diese Hausnummer,
ja dass sie sich da irgend dass es dann Menschen gibt die enviaM fair am am Computer sitzen und sagen jetzt propusten wir irgendwelchen hasse dieses Internet money welche Leute fertig und empfehlen den sich aus,
Gleis zulegen und was da alles für Geschmacklosigkeiten das ist einfach so so so erbärmlich.
Ja ist es auch es ist.
Wir sind eine Familie ich komme aus der Kleinstadt jetzt auch nicht an der Zeitung und ich Kinder Einladung geschrieben hat damit du dass das Hammer Fräser Briefen gehabt.
Na die waren wohl auch nicht besser nur die haben halt mitgekriegt so als Außenstehender.
Jetzt steht das halt da.
Es wird es heute siehst du es halt ne und und leichter geworden sich mitzuteilen also ich glaube auch dass die Meinung nicht anders dieser dass dieses dieses Verhalten nicht neu ist es nur jetzt wie Menschen auch einfacher geworden sich damit auszudrücken sind verhalten.
Durchhalte ich muss nicht mehr wohin fahren um mich zu beschimpfen ich kenne das von der Couch aus machen wie praktisch ist das denn.
Ja aber also das da kommen wir nicht weiter und ich fahre mich auch was das,
also welches Bier ist auch unklar welches sinnvolle Ziel die meinen zu verfolgen ja also wenn du da sitzen uns in einem Infokrieg legst du kannst doch deine Informationen verbreiten wie du willst es gibt hier keinen,
das ist vor allem doch kein Ines ist doch nicht Infokrieg wenn die sich bemühen andere Leute fertig zu machen wir haben doch die haben doch ihre Meinungsfreiheit.
Vergessen dass die Nazis in den Staaten infowars die Seite,
das gleiche Prinzip dann sagen also wir müssen hier diesen Infokrieg führen weil die anderen die ganze Zeit falsch Informationen verbreiten und so die konstruiert Info kriegen sie führen.
Na also.
Dennis ist das doch nur die digitale totenkopfstandarte der AFD und wie also ich meine dafür.
Ja ja aber die ist.
Die sich ins Zeug und dass es ihrer Organisation.
Schon bevor sie achte gab übrigens das getan.
FB totenkopfstandarte.
Ich gebe zu ich habe ein bisschen gelacht dass es gehört habe.
Natürlich.
Aber da ist nichts gegen die lnp Einhorn Standarte musst du nicht dir helfen.
Darf ich ein bisschen Sorgen kurz, Rezept.
Ja
Weißt du was ich auch im Netz organisiert übrigens die Bundeswehr.
Balloncentrum.
Nee wir haben wir haben ja jetzt feiert etwa Republica die ist jetzt vorbei und der Rest war letztes Jahr schon.
Hatte die Bundeswehr sich ja bemüht dort auch einen Stand zu bekommen.
Und sie war auch mit einem Vertreter da bei dem Medikament habe ich mich entschied hochgehalten dass er auch Mörder sind.
Da wollte ich gerade drauf wieder also die Bundeswehr sich letztes Jahr schon bemüht bei der Republica einen Stand zu bekommen und das hat nicht funktioniert wegen ja tut es leid alle Stände sind weg.
Mal einfach.
Dann war auf der Media Convention welche ja eine Sub Konferenz der Republica ist wo nicht das Republica Team das programm kuratiert.
Genauso wichtig.
Ein Podium wo dann der ich glaube Dirk Feldhaus heißen.
Genau der Warte der die Hubers Teekampagne gemacht hat und die Rekruten Video Sendung ist von ihm.
Genau das ist ja der der Beauftragte für die Arbeitgebermarke der Bundeswehr.
Ja ja ja.
Und da der war dann da auf diesem Podium und als er dann da.
Ich glaube lass ihn dann das Wort erteilt wurde zum ersten Mal gab es eine einen kurzen eine kurze bunte Protest Intervention den Konfetti Dusche bekommen Hallo Leute haben Schilder hochgehalten und dann war das.
Genau das ist auch wieder ab in.
30 Sekunde oder sowas ne.
Warum fanden wir wichtig damals.
Da wurden Zeichen gesetzt das eben so etwas nicht ohne Protest da stattfindet und das war ja dann noch große Wellen geschlagen weil der.
Video Bayern Video Team und die haben das sind halt eben nicht raus.
Die haben das standardmäßige getan was ebenso ein video Cutter macht wenn er irgendwas auf der Bühne passiert was nicht vorgesehen ist der hat halt den den Stream geschaltet auf das was auf dem Beamer steht ne,
und damit halt das Bühnengeschehen nicht mehr live übertragen was dann noch der Republik Ärger eingehandelt hatte weil sie da den Protest irgendwie unterdrücken würde oder rausgeschnitten hätte,
nee das war in dem Fall eben einfach nicht Standardsituation für so einen Kater für sonlife Typen der das eben macht.
Dann auch noch mal blöd für die für die Republica gelaufen weil sie dann in den Protest noch mal im zweiten Protestwelle war mit der sie,
nichts zu tun haben wollte für diese nichts konnte und jetzt muss man ja auch einfach mal ganz klar sein dieses Republica Team sehr großes Team zentrale Rolle auf jeden Fall Andreas Gebhardt,
Johnny Haeusler Tanja Häusler Markus Beckedahl die also die Gesichter der Republica sind und ebenfalls nicht.
Mittlere zweistellige Anzahl Team haben und helfende und so weiter das sind alles verdammt coole Leute.
Als die als die Bundeswehr dann 2018 stand haben wollte haben die wieder sagen.
Geht irgendwie nicht wegen also wir wollen euch auf jeden Fall nicht in Uniform da haben.
Und jetzt wollten diese wollten diese Bundis da hatten sich offenbar eingebildet sie könnten da jetzt auf dieser Republik Anstand machen,
indem sie natürlich für sich selber werben also wir haben ja,
seit einiger Zeit eben eine Freiwilligenarmee das heißt die müssten die müssen ja auch jetzt wirklich rekrutieren ich bin ja noch aus der Generation.
Wissen2go.
Ja natürlich wo das eigentlich ein Prozessor wo die sich eben zumindest aus dem männlichen Teil der Bevölkerung eben bedienen konnten.
Musste man daneben verweigern und Zivildienst machen was ich jetzt erstmal gar nicht so schlimm fand ist aber ein anderes Thema die sind natürlich jetzt die brauchen.
Die haben die brauchen Personal die müssen dafür werben das tun sie das wollten sie auch auf dieser Republik cartoon oder hat die Republica gesagt 8 bis Harvard wir haben irgendwie genug Anfragen wir werden unsere Plätze auch so los und wir im Rahmen unserer.
Wie sagt man dass unser wirtschaftlichen Freiheit entscheiden wir uns diese Plätze anders zu vergeben und lehnt ab so was ich finde was jetzt erstmal völlig in Ordnung.
Aus dem Bach die Ansage wenn dann sowieso nicht in Uniform.
Was noch und dann sich.
Also nicht in Flecktarn und auch nicht in der Ausgehuniform Acetal richtig finde aber das auch mal anderes Leben aber dann muss man halt so nee.
Wenn in Unifarben weil die resultierend Uniform. Die machen Tiere in Vorständen Uniform aber das ist jetzt so kann das wenn ich Republica wäre gegangen habe Pech gehabt.
Oh das hat die Republica auch getan und ich finde das also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob.
Die Opfer gibt wird sie auch für kritisiert klar alles was irgendein Mensch irgendwo jemals tut wird dann auch kritisiert ich finde das.
Schon sinnvolles Argument zu sagen hier ist irgendwie eine Versammlung der Zivilgesellschaft wir haben Menschen aus aller Welt die haben in aller Welt Erfahrungen gemacht auch mit Uniform.
Auch auf der Flucht.
So und.
Gebiete alles bei.
Die CD ist das nicht unbedingt cool wenn da im Leute mit Flecktarn rumstehen und insofern verbieten wir uns das finde ich völlig in Ordnung.
Finde ich finde ich auch.
Pimpcity Stirn in.
Ich kann das alles nachvollziehen soll natürlich ist es so dass dass dass die Republikaner die Freiheit hat sich sozusagen ihre.
Partnerin auszusuchen so.
Bin ich mir aber dann so die anderen Partner so anschauen die da großflächig auf den Werbetafeln vertreten sind könnte man natürlich da auch zu diverse Diskussionen aufbringen.
Kommen auch immer wieder.
Spiel und so ja sag nur das ist zurzeit auch Teil des Ganzen also die ganze Veranstaltung stellt sich schon sehr.
Sehr in den den Schatten ihrer Sponsoren finde ich die haben viel Raum viel Sichtbarkeit.
Ich mag ja generell dieses Spawn zatox Ding überhaupt nicht findet es völlig daneben mir letzte Mal auch schon,
auch über dieses diese merkwürdige Dualität damit samedia Convention gesprochen dass du da quasi eine Veranstaltung machst für die du dich da feiern lässt und dann hast du aber irgendwie noch meine zweite,
Blätter andere kuratierung die dann mit dem einen nicht zu tun hat und wenn die was falsch machen fällt natürlich auch auf die anderen zurück und so also.
Ich finde dass das so Internet im Internet Gesamtheit.
Auch schwierig ist aber die Bundeswehr hat sich natürlich jetzt hier auch so bekloppt verhalten dass so eine Diskussion gar nicht geführt werden kann.
Ich komme nicht dazu was hat die Bundesliga getan die Bundeswehr.
War beleidigt.
Hatten hatten beleidigt und hatten Entrup quengeln da Soldaten abkommandiert.
Mit Radio an Afterbuy.
Mit mit Radio Andernach.
Unbewerteter.
Mit was.
Radio Andernach das ist ja Truppen sender.
Unbeweglicher die sind das waren die beiden Frau Hauptmann in Ausgehuniform also in der Galerie Form und die beiden.
Anderen Wanne in Flecktarn und ja das Magistrate offizielle Truppen Radio und Fernsehsender waren jeweils da die kannst du.
Und die andern ist ein Traktor gesessen.
Die haben aber sie haben gefilmt wenn diese Leute wenn die beiden Flecktarn.
FARC was da passiert ist also da war so.
Getan haben ist sie haben eine das was man geringer Marketingaktionen nennt gemacht sie haben sich irgendwie so ein LKW gemietet.
Bei der Leine.
Gut von mir aus an den eigenen,
mit zum mit seiner Plakat Stellwand drauf und da stand dann drauf wir finden zu bunt gehört auch grün haben irgendwelche Postkarten gemacht haben die Leuten da verteilt und haben dann das Ding umgemünzt in die Republica.
Schließt aus ihrem Hund das Grün aus sie lässt sie sie schließt die Bundeswehr aus wir wir finden,
wir stellen uns im Dialog die Republica,
schließt uns aus ja und das haben sie dann flankiert mit ihrem eigenen SocialMedia Team und so weiter und haben dann außerdem noch irgendwelche Twitter Claqueure da gehabt die,
die dann irgendwie dass das rp-18 Hashtag irgendwie mit mit Jubel und Republica Kritik,
geflutet haben über die aktuelle Aktion der Bundeswehr hier so ähnlich wie die elitären erstellen Sie hier wieder Tor,
und haben sie auf einmal zweihundert Leute auf Twitter dieser tolle Aktion man ist das kreativ Jungs das hat die Bundeswehr auch gemacht und ich hätte haben sie auch noch irgendwie eine koordinierte Facebook Download 3,
des Events Republica jawohl jetzt dann irgendwie ein Sternebewertung die Veranstalter verschließen sich den Dialog mit dem Militär.
Wann ist die ganze Zeit weil ich meine die Bundeswehr tut er so als ob sie Grundrechts regieren wer in dem Augenblick Menschenrechte auf Teilnahme an das ist ja schon mal nicht.
Ja oder nicht Menschenrecht aber es gab ja auch so Argumentation mit na ja die Veranstaltung wird ja vom Staat auch gefördert weil er welche Fördergelder drin dann müssen wir ja als Teil dieses Staates da auch vertreten sein.
Würde ich sehr schwierig.
Das ist auch totaler Bullshit wenn ich meine Fragen wir mal so unser unsere Ministerien irgendwie jetzt so hier.
Meteo Immigration irgendwie Patte fließt durch den gemacht und dann die Bundeswehr dabei sein sollte also ist mal was wird gesagt das wird mich auch.
Ja oder irgendein anderer Teil des Staates also mit Bundeswehr ist ja jetzt.
Finanzminister hatte die Bundeswehr bei sich zu Hause sitzen.
Also wir haben ja jetzt Werner jetzt ne das ist schon ein einmaliger Vorgang das ist eine Veranstaltung der Zivilgesellschaft.
Wo die von der Bundeswehr koordiniert medial angegriffen wird.
Angegriffen mit einer koordinierten Kampagne die sich gegen diese Veranstaltung richtet,
spezifische Kritik an der Republica die Veranstalter der reitet dass das Militär quasi ein diese Leute die da demonstriert haben ne.
Seit langem Dienst alle übrigens ne wie habe ich demonstriert weil du bist der kann nicht demonstr.
Dürfen auch Gaststätten für Wörter wurden ja wirklich quasi Soldaten und Soldatinnen abkommandiert Einsatzbefehl so oder also heutige heute machen wir so ne Hirsche Postkarten.
Jemand vor gedrückt haben muss um sie unterschrieben haben.
Die sieht so das haben die geplant und ich muss da muss man zumindest mal anerkennen diese Aktion.
Die war gut gemacht handwerklich.
Ja Handwerk das ja.
Handwerklich haben die das gut hingekriegt da haben die haben offenbar ja sowieso ganz findige Werbekampagne.
Mittlerweile ja.
Die mit ihrem die Dinger die die machen die die hier tapezieren da sind.
Mitunter mal ganz gute Wortwitze dabei diese Youtuber Kampagne diese man da sind Leute die verstehen ihr Handwerk und die haben es eben auch verstanden diesen Aspekt dass sie da.
Kein Slot bekommen haben und nicht als Sponsor sich eine Bude mieten konnten zu skandalisieren und dafür zu sorgen dass wir das da jetzt alle möglichen Leute drüber sprechen.
Die Bundeswehr wieder überall erwähnt wird auch.
Bundeswehr überall erwähnt wird aber das ist sicher als Opfer hinzustellen das ist ein einmaliger Vorgang und das ist.
Verein darf man uns vergessen die den Uniform den Waffen im Zweifel ne also Opfer Entschuldigung.
Zeig mir die sich während und vor allem ich meinen aber das ist ja schon jetzt also das ist echt nur Fortführung von dem was ihr seid schon tun gamescom wo sie irgendwie Umstände haben wo halt Gamer.
Sind und versuche Jugendliche zu rekrutieren wir werden uns so viel Minderjährige Salaten wie noch nie.
Füge und Rami ne also das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen zu diesem Komplex auch wieder.
Was meinst du mit wir werden so viele.
Na ja wir haben so viel Minderjährige Soldaten wie lange nicht mehr in der Bundeswehr du darfst doch nicht wer oder was Verhalten geht klar.
Ich kann die Zahlen nicht ich dachte die hätten generell Probleme irgend.
Ja hammer aber es ist wie immer junge junge Menschen also auch nicht genug um die Lücken zu füllen aber.
Aber wenn du sagst wie noch nie in Mainz zu Zeiten der Wehrpflicht.
Keiner kennt man nicht minderjährig 18 erstmal und nicht mit 17.
Verstärker.
Also du hast elliphant ich bin einfach einhalten.
Aber was ist also.
Und wo habe ich in der Ausbildung ist die Bundeswehr sich momentan geriert bei dieser Beiträge gesehen wo sie von sich selbst spricht als unsere Parlamentsarmee.
Ich finde nicht von euch sagen ihr seid also geht nicht und die die nämlich immer gerade immer mehr raus also auch sind der Meinung sie haben überall dabei zu sein oder so auch die,
dürfen oder an Schulen sprechen wenn Lehrer Sie einladen ne,
dann müssen wir eingeladen werden ich mir das vor wenn sie es noch nicht angemeldet sind ist dann von der Schule damals geht das nicht rein dürfen das ist ja ne also also fahren was hat die zu demonstrieren,
das ist nicht ihr Job zu demonstrieren jedoch ist es irgendwie Hubschrauber zum Tauchen sie auch nicht hin,
ja also also das kannst du es ist beispiellos es ist ich glaube das gab es auch seit 45 nicht mehr.
So verhalten ne also das ist springt jeden jede Kette und ich meine wir.
Wenn wir schon Armee haben bin ich froh dass es eine Parlamentsarmee ist und irgendwie Konzept Staatsbürger in Uniform lala kann man auch wieder streiten weil die Dinger stimmt oder sind lieber so als anders aber.
Diese Stadt sind unifarben reparieren sich gerade in dem sich raus und was Besseres zu sein.
In ihrer Uniform als Organisation wichtiger zu sein als der Rest da draußen weil sie diesen Raum haben.
Dürfen 50er Meinung dich überhaupt nicht zusteht sie dürfen sich nicht mehr kann ich nehmen.
Ich denke also der steht in überhaupt nicht zu und es darf auch als ich denke das wird auch ein ausführliches Nachspiel haben.
Ich mir nicht vorstellen kann dass das in Ordnung ist also wir reden ja wirklich von einem spezifischen Angriff gegen eine zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation ja mit.
Steuergelder ja das.
Mache ich was bezahlen.
Die Bundeswehr als politischer Akteur an dieser Stelle gegen eine gegen eine Jagd zivilgesellschaftliche Veranstaltung in das kann nicht sein.
Ja und das ist mich sehr spannend dieses die Bundeswehr als politischer Akteur sie haben ja schon viel länger bei Landespolizeien.
Jagdhörner G20 hat die Polizei ja sehr gut gehandelt,
gleiches Prinzip also gleiches Problem auch und ich meine auch sehr schön die würde verstanden so der zweite Reihe parken.
Das sind ja so Verwaltungsvorschriften technisch ne die hätten sie hat mich besonders Sondernutzungsrechte gehabt da mit seiner Mama nachhakt dann halt natürlicher den 124 unterschrieben jemand bezahlt,
also irgendwo in der Kette musst du eine gute Idee gehalten haben in der Bundeswehr,
unser meistens die dienten nicht nur einfach irgendwie Streifen und im Winkl drauf haben wir uns irgendwann anfangen wo ist langsam wie lange Zeit auf der Schulterklappe.
Dass ich finde ich will nicht alles schwierig ja das ist also Inhalt eigentlich geht es nicht da habe ich davon recht Linus und das darf auch nie wieder passieren ich weiß auch schon dass die ersten Anfragen Bundestag geschrieben worden sind.
Freunde von mir sind bei einigen Abgeordneten Angestellte habe ich das erfahren es gibt auch frag den Staat schon die ersten an,
Fragen hast du nämlich den jetzt um den und den Schriftwechsel dass er veröffentlicht werden soll und ein paar andere Sachen,
ich bin gespannt was bei rauskommt nicht hoffe dass das nicht im Sande verläuft weil oder nicht so endet wie bei G20 Jahr wir können keine Fehler der Polizei feststellen.
Da wir waren ein paar schöne Reflektionen über diesen Vorfall hier bei unseren Bundeswehr Bloggern vor allem bei Augen geradeaus.
Thomas Wiegold.
Und beim Bendlerblock.
Hund.
Schön ein Zitat vielleicht aus dem Benzer block and scroll.
Eine staatliche Institution die sich wie ein beleidigter Pennäler aufführt weil sie nicht mitspielen darf weil sie sich nicht an die Spielregeln halten will ist intellektuell in der Pubertät stecken geblieben.
Na das passt ja zum Alter der Soldaten.
Ja was geht es ich glaube tatsächlich es geht hier also dass das ist dir schon klar aber die haben hier eine erfolgreiche Social Media Kampagne gefahren.
Ja und nicht nur das.
Und und das und zwar gegen eine zivilgesellschaftliche Konferenz.
Na ja erfolgreich von dir wenn sie auf die Sophia noch.
Was ist eine Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie.
Ja nicht genau sie haben ja auch direkt von Anfang an das Gefühl von Twitter weggezogen auf Facebook was auch sehr spannend war weil auf Facebook Hansen war sehr große Fanbasis.
Das siehst Du halt auch in Leiste die Idee die Werbekampagne abgefeuert die Truppe wird gefeiert als solches von zu viel Menschen dort sieht man Menschen Soldaten,
gut finden das ist nunmal so und das Wetter wohl also gratis Republica Umfeld es halt auf Twitter der er jetzt.
Ich habe eine Bundeswehr zwingend.
Aber nicht so wie sich aufgeführt haben zumindest und Japan durch Aufnahmen Hase und wir müssen auch die Bundeswehr sich genötigt die Paprika zu rügen.
Hoffe dass es nicht ginge solches.
Was genau nicht ginge.
Na dass ich probiere ausschließt.
Also wenn man muss es ja andersrum drehen ne also was zwingt sie irgendjemand einzuschließen so ne.
Ja genau das ist es ja das ist also die ganze.
Und ich hatte noch Freitag gekommen hast du auch einen Link lässt dieser Artikel ist sehr spannend gewesen von Daniel Lücking der Vase ist nah bei der Bundeswehr wenn ich das richtig mit diesem Artikel und Wahrheit bei.
Sagen wir mal eher so Informationen sammeln Teil der Truppe wenn ich richtig verstehe.
Er kennt ihn auf jeden Fall und.
Und der hat wohl auch geschrieben ist da waren wo Soldaten im Dienst und er ist ja jetzt mit einer List und plötzlich hat man im zivil.
Und in Jeans ist hier sehr spannend na da hat er uns ein Problem dann als Journalist der sein privates Gespräch hat das Hans-Joachim Dienst und Janina privates Gespräch und A und auch was Soldaten die im Dienst Damen Uniform.
Das ein Problem darstellt ne also bis jetzt wohl da also ja.
Ja gut wenn du sagst ich soll nicht in Uniform kommen.
Na du kannst aber noch anders markieren dass sie Soldaten sind wie viel Tage nämlich lustige Bundesadler am Revers wenn sie sonst irgendwie rumlaufen ne.
Und ist halt also ich finde es kann dieser sehen kann ich sehr gespannt diesen Artikel hat diesen Aspekt so das ist hier irgendwie die Ada die.
Ja die Tennisabteilung war sie und.
Ich habe das hat mir mehr Sorgen gemacht oder fast noch dieses ganz ganz beschreiben ihre hat macht als das die Bundeswehr darf ein kleines Kind Aufstand weil das kriegst du dann mal mitgekriegt alle.
Artikel muss dieser Titel musst du lesen halt erst muss etwas finden und lesen.
Was machst du denn was machst du denn wenn jetzt die nächste Friedensdemo irgendwo stattfindet ja und dann rennen die Leute darum mit ihrer mit ihrer blauen Fahne mit der weißen.
Lorbeer.
Habe so und dann stellt sich die Bundeswehr dahin und verteilt Flyer und beleidigt irgendwie diese Friedensaktivisten.
Das geht halt nicht klar.
Aber genau diese Grenze hat die Bundeswehr hier überschritten.
Natürlich hat sie das.
Und das geht nicht das geht einfach grundsätzlich nie.
Ich finde es aber halt auch im gesamten Gesamtbild mit zusammen was was dagegen da schreibt noch Fifi erschrecken eigentlich solange auch wieder schreibt über Menschen auf Twitter die wohl irgendwie dienstlich sind aber auch nicht.
Na also das ist wo der Grenze verschwimmt das ist alles ziemlich ziemlich schwierig und macht mir Sorgen und auch das Verhalten der Bundeswehr macht mir.
Sorgen ich hatte das Gefühl dass die letzten ja sowieso schon sehr viel Anführungszeichen selbstbewusste Auftritt als als Armee als in den Jahren vorher gerade weil sie halt rekrutieren muss finde ich auch schon bemerkenswert auch sehr schwierig.
Guten versucht zu diskutieren sie muss rekrutieren als e-mail weil sonst hat sie nicht gut Personal.
Aber die Affen Weise wie sie sich sich darstellt und geriert mich einmal als moderner als normaler Arbeitgeber der sie nicht ist.
Arbeitgebermarke Bundeswehr wer das sagt ja auch schon ganz ganz viel aus die ist kein normaler Arbeitgeber sie sind hat immer noch so sind immer die Menschen mit den Waffen Panzer und Flugzeuge U-Booten,
und einfach dazu gehört und bereit prinzipiell mit der Waffe Krieg zu führen.
Und das ist nicht normal Arbeitgeber und auch wenn sie ganz viel angeblich tun würden für Heimat Familie und arbeiten und bla das ist mir alles egal.
Das ist immer noch diejenigen die in Zweiflingen fliegt sie werden und das sind nicht normale aber nur dass ich nicht Angst haben spontan erschossen zu werden.
Und das ist also das ist normal bei diesem Job so.
Eine Reihe an Unterschied na du hast den Unterschied dass du da ja auch nicht so einfach kündigen kannst dich,
schlechteste Gibson Teil deiner Grundrechte auf als Soldat da kriegst dafür ein paar Sonderrechte zum Beispiel andere Menschen zu töten ist ja auch.
Vorne rechts vor allem in anderen Ländern aber das ist normal dass es jetzt,
noch mal ein anderes Thema als spezifisch diese Aktion wo,
die Bundeswehr denke ich eine eine Grenze überschritten hat die hoffentlich gerügt wird und die so in dieser Form nicht Schule machen darf wenn man sich überlegt wenn ihr es jetzt in Zukunft überall machen.
Und du das gerade auch schon angesprochen Polizei auch immer öfter als politischer Player und,
stell dir mal vor demnächst demonstriert die Polizei an irgendeiner Stelle,
irgendetwas die Polizei kann genaue für eine Sache der demonstrieren nehme ich dafür dass sie irgendwie neue Autos oder oder bessere Uniform haben wollen oder oder eine Leine die Kinder kein Lohn sondern was auch immer wieder kriegen Erhöhung der Bezüge.
Dafür können die von mir aus demonstrieren aber die oder die könnten mal demonstrieren dass der Rainer Wendt endlich nicht mehr ihr gewerkschaftsvorsitzender ist dass es steht den alles frei aber das ist eben ihre eigenen Belange.
So
Sag ja auch immer alles so schlimm wie der Bundeswehr.
Vor allem das Lied findest auch ein bisschen bei die Bundeswehr sich herab lässt irgendwie da so so ein Facebook koordinierten downvoting Kampagne oder so.
Ich kann ja auch die Postkarten großartig ist auf eine gewisse Art und Weise.
Also letzteres finde ich insbesondere also jetzt nicht die Postkarten habe ich nicht mitbekommen aber so dieses Mal haben sie da wirklich zu aufgerufen negative Bewertung zu machen also sehr ist also es war auf jeden Fall die Folge davon so nah.
Ryanair negativ Bewertungen für das Event auf Facebook die immer wieder gleich begründet sind so und sowas wird ich glaube nicht dass die Bundeswehr jetzt irgendwie intern den Befehl gegeben hat,
aber so was machst Du doch in der Regel über.
Fieber ausgelöst.
So was machst du indem du halt z.b. auf dieses Event verlinkt und sagst hier wo wir ausgeladen.
Ja und man darf man nicht vergessen dass bei einem Kommentaren ab und auf dem Facebook posten,
auch wenn wieder Sachen schon die einmarschieren lala die Moderatoren der Bundeswehr jetzt nicht zwingend,
sich sagen gut gehandelt haben sondern auch mit irgendwie mit danke und mit zwinkersmileys km und haben also ein Kram halt ne also die haben auch da nichts für Gitarren Zustimmung irgendwie nicht nicht nicht zu erhalten.
Nein nein nein ganz im Gegenteil und isst du liest ja auch in jedem Artikel es gibt einen breiten Proteststurm gegen die Entscheidung der Republica ja was.
Und da bin ich ja auch drauf reingefallen dass ich da irgendwie durch diesen Hashtag der Republica scrolle und sie dann irgendwie einen Twitter-Nutzer der Wiese,
da halt applaudiert ne geile Aktion der Bundeswehr und dann habe ich.
Das als Beispiel rausgesucht nachgesagt Soja was ist das für ein dieses Publikum spielt auch noch mit bei dieser blöden Aktion der Bundeswehr und dann wurde ich halt von Daniela King darauf hingewiesen das war einer von der,
geh mal kurz darauf eben auf Nachfrage twitterte dass er dort im Dienst ist.
Man.in Dienst ne also auf der Fahne und diese Postkarten wird schon darauf zurückkommen die sind Flecktarn bedruckt in den Seasons klassische Plakat Layout und dann wir kämpfen auch dafür dass die Republica gegen uns sein kann und das klingt halt so als ob sie die.
Der Republica ist Uniform zu unbequem die Konferenz steht für Offenheit und Toleranz trotzdem schließt die deutsche Soldatinnen und Soldaten in Uniform aus sollte sie das diskutiert mit uns Bundeswehr Karriere auf Facebook.
Bundeswehr kann die postcard drucken lassen.
Das ist das ist so das was man so normalerweise bei Nazis als Argumentation kommt ne.
Genau vor allem wir kämpfen auch dafür dass sie Republica gegen uns sein kann weil wir gerade von den.
Weil wenn ich Sponsor sein durften.
Japan tabalugaland was bedroht ist das ziemlich nicht gegen die Bundeswehr sein kann was was ist eine Ratte droht akut irgendwie der defix abgeschaltet wird oder ich finde auch.
Jan van ich meine was ist denn das auch für eine Haltung also meine ganzer von abgesehen dass man sie im Prinzip ja die Republica quasi mit Nazidemos in einen Topf wirft.
Schonmal garnicht geht so und meine,
das Selbstverständnis der Bundeswehr Bücher auch eine gewisse Sympathie für entwickeln kann sodass man sagt so na ja wir sind ja hier Teil eines freiheitlichen Staates und wir wollen uns ja auch für die Freiheit einsetzen dass man dann auf einmal so eine Aktion macht gegen eine Konferenz die einfach mal tief in diesem.
Freiheitlichen Grund denken verwurzelt ist und sich genau da immer positioniert und wo das ja auch sauer mal.
Kernser ganze Argumentation von der Republica Seite auch auch ist das geht halt einfach mal gar nicht weil ich an dieser Stelle.
Kann die Bundeswehr mir erzählen was sie will,
da machte sich jetzt einfach mal nicht so einem neutralen Teilnehmer dieses Staates ja der sozial für die gesamte Gesellschaft da ist und beziehen Sie einfach mal Gras Stellung und schießen scharf wenn auch nur mit.
Karten genau gegen eine Gruppierung und Hetz Inhalt potenzielle auch Leute auf den Hals wo ich sagen muss so dass es nicht so die Art von Leuten wo ich gerne sehen möchte dass sie sich bei der Bundeswehr engagieren weil das führt in die falsche Richtung.
Und was ich mir bei der Postkarte muss ich schreiben die Konferenz fit für aufhalten Toleranz trotzdem schießt die Soldaten Soldaten aus ist genauso sprach Verschiebung wie bei den Tieren.
Sind ja auch nicht das ist ja nicht so dass Soldaten kein Zutritt gehabt hätten.
Das Wetter in Uniform Fernseher zu.
Oder was ist halt was ihren Versuchen ausdrücken ist das ist Intoleranz Verhalten sei weil ich eine Uniform nicht haben möchte das nicht so Toleranz zu tun eine Uniform ist was selbstgewähltes.
Frauen tolerieren in der Freiwilligen haben ne kannst du mal Klamotten anziehen kannst du gerne kommen.
Ja aber so wenn da die Polizei in Uniform ist.
Sebatop dann sind im Dienst.
Ja die ist auch für sowas zuständig dann genau da.
Die Bundeswehr im Inneren der Republik,
zeige mir fällt ja weil es reicht schon wenn Feld leer beim beim beim Oktoberfest stehen und mitmachen schieben wir schon schlimm genug weil es mich auch irgendwie nicht gerade sehr einladend aussieht wenn da irgendwie die Feldjäger im Flecktarn und irgendwie hier.
Maschinengewehr rumstehen und.
Ich will nicht mehr Konferenz muss um Zivilgesellschaft geht wo es um Ruf geflüchtete Menschen sprechen wo es um drum geht also wie komme am Krieg vorbei quasi diskutieren wir in eine Welt zusammen leben wollen am besten ohne Krieg das dann da in der Bundeswehr.
Kommt und irgendwie sagt ja wenn ich gegen zeit also wir kämpfen für das ist deine Spielseite aber also wir müssen doch schon haben wollen wie wir.
Wie werden die Wetter nächsten größeren Friedensdemo werden die diese Dinger machen mit dieser für Frieden demonstriert wenn wir kämpfen die ganze Zeit für Frieden und dürfen nicht mitmachen.
Genau das alles ist schlimm.
Genau flight als Abschlusssatz den letzten Satz in den Blogpost von Thomas Wiegold von Augen geradeaus.
Was sagt ach noch als Randbemerkung die hämischen Bemerkung der Bundeswehr über die fehlende Toleranz der Republik Amacher heben wir uns mal auf und gucken bei der nächsten,
gemerkt friedlichen Protestaktion bei einer Bundeswehr Veranstaltung wie sieht die Feldjäger da benehmen.
Oh ja sehr.
Die Toleranz.
Das ist doch genauso Kopf ach egal ja super.
So, jetzt.
Zu anderen interessanten alle anderen beliebten Organisationen.
Such mir noch auf der Liste.
Stefan du hast ein Artikel geschrieben bei Golem.de mit dem Titel Kleinganoven überforderter Hotline und ein einfaches Konto worum ging es da.
Erstmal tief ist nicht von mir die hat Skoda gemacht also das ging um Schufa meine Lieblinge von der Schufa in großer Fan.
Das auch mal meine Schufa durch die Gegend ganzer so kennt man dich.
Postkarten Foto.
Und als hätte der Titel geschrieben weil es ist.
Konto aufmachen selbständig gemacht wir wissen Verlag dann jetzt Beratung und wollten alten Konto klicken wo ich heute irgendwie so viel habe ich zu ihr komfortables Konto nicht irgendwelche neumodische fintech scheiße da ne.
Und dann krieg ich so schicke dich Glück ttip und drücke auf absenden und hat sich das wupp abgelehnt ebenso.
Um den Bliesheim aber that the first da.
Letzten Jahren öfter könnten geöffnet und geschlossen ich habe Kredit umgeschuldet also alles ich habe am Finanz Leben teilgenommen ist schon heiß und das obwohl ich einen negativen Eintrag hatte wegen Sache wo ich vor Gericht wird verglichen hatten wir trotzdem angefangen,
Villach egal.
Der war es auf dem jahrelangen drinne und der ist jetzt ja gelöscht worden okay er hat alles drinne aber ich fand ja sonst immer Konten eröffnen.
Kreditkarte neu beantragen kein Thema gewesen Kredite umschulden alles kein Ding.
Wird wohl nicht das Problem sein und rufe ab gibt's hier einmal im Jahr noch akut 34 BDSG.
Musste irgendwie Ausweis kopieren hinschicken paper.
Das ist die eTIN die kostenlose Datenauskunft die man einmal im Jahr bei der Schufa machen kann.
Die jeder Operation einmal im Jahr machen muss sie würdigt Datenspeicher nicht mehr die Schufa sind alle müssen das tun genau die ist das dann habe ich meine ich habe ja gut dann schicken dass wir Christiane ja zum Glück lesen ich bin ja gelernter Bankkaufmann.
Müssen wir meine ich habe meine gerade wieder wegen deines Artikels habe ich nämlich wieder eine Anfrage gemacht die ist gestern gekommen ich verstehe dabei.
Ja auf jeden Fall ja dann können sprech mir bei Gelegenheit auf jeden Fall war es nicht in der Reinigung Kongress andere Sachen zu tun oder so,
TV Futter reinigen so ja läuft.
Mein mein Mobilfunkvertrag man mein telefon mein Konto manuell vom Vertrag Mobilfunk Mobilfunkvertrag.
Wo sind denn die Telefonica Deichmann letzten Mobilfunkvertrag über 10 Jahren gehabt.
Ja das sollte man auch das gehört sich also das machen wir ja da geht man ja weg.
Folgt mir also noch wie alt sie noch Birk Intercom hießen übrigens ne.
Die haben schöne Tüten habe ich letztens in Köln gesehen wo drauf steht wann wechselst du ich rufe doch gerade gesagt hättest du alles.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich gedacht du rufst oder mal an Papa was soll weil ihr nicht meine sind ja nicht meine und ich bin ich das nachher wiperti nachher noch kommt nicht verzier Stammhalter.
Angerufen und äußerst nette Person am Telefon hat ein Freund von mir hat die auch noch Anwältin ist lautsprecher an,
und eigentlich hatte so ja ich habe hier so eine Schufa-Abfrage sich verträgt also ich weiß nichts davon Hallo.
Schufa Eintrag Nummer der bedeutet dass du diesen Vertrag hast da steht nicht du hättest den du bitte nicht bezahlen oder.
Nein habe einen lauf jetzt Vertrag aber 5 Handyverträge sind Anhänger Holz.
Und das gilt dann das steht in der Schufa deshalb drin.
Waldi Handy Unternehmen anmelden als Paar.
Hat ein Handy und dann warum warum steht das da überhaupt drin weil das ein Indikator ist.
Merchify ich habe ich habe schon drei Stück und will noch fünf haben und habe das Esszimmer viel Kredite und Hypothek willst du mir eingeben.
Okay also das der beste eingetragen weil es seinen Lauf.
Mal etwas Merkmal ist über Verbindlichkeiten die also die vielleicht auch höher sein könnten dass der Preis steht nicht drinne aber halt dass der Verpflichtungen sind für mich Zahlungsverpflichtung.
Deswegen glätten lassen das Unternehmen eintragen wie bezahlen ja also mach auf meine Anfrage bei der Schufa Hauptzollamt also ob ich meine Ringgröße ist das Bedienen könnte so ein Vertrag.
Scheinfirma geklappt.
Hier und Jetzt wann Fehler jetzt also da sind Einträge du hättest Verbindlichkeiten mit dem Unternehmen Viereck Intercom.
Ich hätte ich hätte ich hätte ich hätte Verträge bei Telefonica laufen die hat Verbindlichkeiten darstellen weil ich dir jemand bedienen muss.
Mit anderen Worten mein gerade ausgelaufener gekündigter Vertrag der Telefonica kann ich jetzt mal kontrollieren.
Aber raus ist genau genau.
Der Ordner in meiner Schufa Liste drin steht super heißt doch was.
Etwas zu tun und dann habe ich angerufen wieder mit dem Frau mich und halt 14 diese Einträge sind nicht von mir sind von Poltern Daten nathanja wo wohnen sie nicht hier ist meine Adresse Stefanie ja was ist denn geboren mein Guthaben gesagt.
Haben Sie ein Konto bei der Wiener Sparkasse.
Route Urbach billiges jetzt mal auf und schreibe eine Anzeige wegen Betrug die schicken Kopie und das ist ja schon immer raus.
Verträge wurden bedient von dem Konto das nicht meins ist und die Luft man nicht sagen von wem das ist.
Ich vermute und das ist nämlich auch mehr als öfters wir glauben irgendeine Rentnerinnen und Rentner die im Heim sitzen halt dement die nicht mehr mitkriegen wenn der Mann 30er fehlt jeden Morgen vom Konto merken die das nicht ne irgendwas werden bezahlt die Verträge wurden bedient.
Also du meinst hat jemand quasi auf deinen Namen einen Mobilfunkvertrag angemeldet.
Genau die wurde auch woanders hingeschickt die SIM-Karte wird an Adresse dazu gemeldet hast nur mein Geburtsdatum mein Name haben gestimmt reicht aber schon.
Und die verträgt sich SIM-Karten wurden an einen an einen anderen Ort geschickt wo ich nicht wohne und noch nie gewohnt habe und die Verträge wird von einem Konto das nicht meines ist bedient.
Die Vermutung die auf die Polizei hat ist das da jemand einfach saubere Handys haben wollte.
Im Sinne von kann nach der mitgespielt Aktivitäten wie Drogenhandel was auch immer.
Oder dass sie verschlingt schlechter Schufa keine Handyverträge mehr machen konntet.
Oder das sah so irgendwie auf jeden Fall so ziemlich darum dass die Verträge zu haben und nicht zu bedienen und irgendwie jemanden zu schaden also im Sinne von.
Der soll mal jetzt auf haben schon.
Der wollte einfach in Ruhe Handy an.
Unruhen Handy haben die Tasten haben nicht drauf ne das ist sag dir bescheid zu mir am Telefon auch das kommt öfter vor erzählt auch heutzutage wird einfach nur saubere Handys haben wollen.
Ja digga ja soviel sim-karten-registrierung und sonst was los ist kann man sich ja vorstellen dass es in bestimmten Bereichen der Wirtschaft Bedarf daran gibt Telefone zu haben.
Die jetzt nicht bei einer Standard Anfrage nach der also so.
Zumal du meinem Vertrag musst du keinen keinen keinen Ausweis vorlegen reklamations Catalyst Handyvertrag Konto und das ehrlich mit Hund select beim Prepaid und hat sie.
Legitimationskette.
Animation sketch beim Prepaid-Handy muss ich mir meinen Ausweis vorzeigen.
Neuerdings.
Vertrag halt mich.
Im Vertrag nicht.
Musst du nicht das Abschließen online und dann hast du ja da du ja ein Konto drin hast ohne Kreditkarte was auch irgendwie.
Und das da das legitimiert wurde.
Delegitimieren dadurch ist eine Kette hergestellt.
Ja gut also dann ist das dann haben wir doch da eine Schutzlücke.
Hast nimm doch nicht Mensch.
Aber es hat sich schon ein bisschen absurd dass man jetzt dadurch dass man keine anonymen SIM-Karten mehr kriegen kann quasi jetzt so ein neuer Fall geschaffen wird wo es einen hohen Anreiz gibt es anderen Leuten in die Schuhe zu schieben.
Und das auch noch problemlos machen kann die dann sozusagen darunter leiden wie ein dann in deinem Fall.
Gut also ich hatte das Glück hatte dass ich jetzt keinen finanziellen Schaden an Kerstin Sinne von wem ist jetzt Schulden Auflauf Winter den Schaden das jetzt mein scheiß Konto haben Muster.
Na ja aber du hast ja eine erhebliche Einschränkungen in deiner genau in der Lebensführung Unterhaltungsmöglichkeit.
Eigentlich viel mehr eingeschränkt um diese Scheiße wieder loszuwerden sein Trainer.
Genau den ganzen Scheiß und das lustig.
Dass ich einen Schweine auf der Weide hast du meine Nachricht bekommen,
direkt live und in Farbe es war ein riesen Akt das loszuwerden dazu das noch Anfragen von Anime Fuhrunternehmen die Erbe abgelehnt worden sind also wahrscheinlich mit Goldrand zu schlecht auch die sollten ja wieder rausschmeißen der falsche anfragen.
Das war bei mobilcom-debitel die haben erstmal was ich wollte.
Also alles ist dramatisch gewesen und die Schufa ist sondern auch jetzt nicht sagen also der der größte Freund deines anruft ne ruf da an und du ja guten Tag das sind Verträge die sind nicht mir.
Sagst du ja und jetzt ist wieder am Anspruch auf löschen BDSG wir sind in der Vertragspartner.
Das ist das gerade kommen wir jetzt.
Ihn haben wir nämlich kein Vertrag.
Überzieh sammeln wir nur ohne jegliche vertragliche Bindung.
Zeig mir nur das Leben ein die anderen sind Kunden.
Vertrag haben wir kein Schnee und also fahren für wirklich so also es war sehr gut aus das war der war nicht der Mensch und habe ich mein hier.
Hallo Problem ist wie folgt die sind nicht von mir das ist falsch lass uns korrigans korrigieren.
Hätte sagen können was suchen wir ja da müssen wir es mal mit dem Prozess mit den jeweiligen Firmen starten und guck mal wo die Daten herkommen und was und ob das jetzt von ihm dieser Wunsch legitim ist.
Das wäre die Antwort gewesen weil mein Mann ist mir scheißegal.
Wie hat sich das größer das genauso.
Genauso gesagt.
Das ist im scheißegal.
Weil ich halt einfach ein Wahnsinn hier also das kann nicht sein das jetzt sagen dass ich das nicht ändern werden weil ich nicht drauf hatte bin ich habe ein Anrecht drauf per Gesetz.
Misfit Nemo dass es sofort löschen muss das wieder auch nicht da drinne ne also ich habe Anrecht drauf natürlich dass die Schufa das prüfen möchte vorher kann ich ja auch irgendwie nachvollziehen ne.
Aber hast du dann ist mir scheißegal bin jetzt nicht so gut und so klug gewählt manchmal dann also auch beim dann habe ich ihre Nummer anrufen könnte.
Kann ich jetzt erstmal nichts mache ich zu aha ich hätte ein später über Twitter gelernt das ist eine Geviert Schutz der Schufa gibt.
Kann man Formular runterladen für das aussieht die Anzeige mit dann kriegst du ein Vermerk rein dass das schon jetzt gibt malvorlag und das dann unter Umständen dann sein Telefon also sind wie funktioniert eine Anfrage gemacht wird.
Was kann man machen bei der Schufa.
Wenn du aber nur wenn so ein Problem schon vorgelegen hat.
Achso erst dann.
Ja aber du kannst mich auch klingen für 395 im Monat den Zugang kaufen wo sie ja jedesmal wenn der Eintrag kommt die E-Mail schicken.
Pass auf Rechnung 90 musst du bezahlen.
Eine Mail nur dass es passiert ist oder wo man das auch explizit bestätigen muss.
Nur das passiert es besteht musst du gar nicht.
Aber ich mein das wär.
Vertragspartner.
Na gut ich denke ja nur darüber nach wie das vielleicht eigentlich.
Ja das 8. gibt ganz viele ganz viele Ideen und Gedanken zur Zeit der Schufa alles Wurst.
Ganz kurz wie bist Du die Sache ist am Ende wie bist du diese Einträge dann losgeworden.
Also Telefonica war recht schnell weil da habe ich halt die Anzeige hingeschickt und ein Brief und hat einen schönen Adresse genannt hatten und da kam eine Woche später Brief zurück dass sie keinerlei Ansprüche gegen mich haben hatten und haben werden auf diesen Verträgen.
Und dass sie die Schufa veranlassen zu löschen.
Na also das Telefonica war ziemlich cool mobilcom-debitel war die halt auch keinen keinen keine E-Mail hinschreiben kann derzeit nur Formular du kannst auch nutzen wenn du eine Kundennummer hast.
Lernvideo dann anruf.
Seien Sie die Kundennummer nicht.
Brauchste Kundennummer.
Du bist kannst du ja jemand anrufen und dann auch nicht dann habe ich ja ich rufe jetzt einfach mal die neu Kundenhotline ab.
Und sie meinte so ja müssen Sie mir danach hinschreiben.
Ich hatte nie mehr rein kommt ein Auto ist man das eingang ist und dann kommt irgendwann eine Mail zurück woher soll er das zwar nicht was ich wollte so habe ich nicht gebeten nehme ich die Infos kein Vertrag erkläre so nee das ist mir egal weiß ich dass es nicht gibt.
Ja wollte auf Reset drücken also schon unten runter also können nicht antworten auf diese Mail sonst kommt von noreply@md.de das Kontaktformular benutzen.
Antworten das ja wir wissen nur als Kunde Funktion.
Ich hatte es hätte genauso einen ähnlichen Ort vor kurzem weil ich auch so Abbuchung von meinem Konto wieder hatte und dann war das und wie eins und eins und bist halt auch da anrufen ja guten Tag ich möchte Ihnen müsste sie auf Missbrauch hinweisen und.
Na 7 davon einen falschen Konto ab und darf ich meine Puppe sagt ja sagen Sie mir doch erstmal Ihre Kundennummer.
Soll haben sie mir eigentlich zugehört und so und dann muss ich da auch irgendwie durch 1000 Instanzen bis dann wirklich mal bei der richtigen Abteilung die sich wirklich um diesen Ford kümmert.
Die waren aber auch sofort so okay ja welche Nummer ja hier Kontonummer ja ich gucke mal kurz und dann so a ja okay.
Mehr Kunden und wie selbe Konto und sag uns läuft man muss halt erstmal durch diesen ersten Level da irgendwie durchkommen.
Wird es weitere Antwortschreiben ja nicht in der Titel die haben es nicht im Krieg mit der E-Mail-Versand hat einen zuständig normal wenn der Kunde angerufen, zweite E-Mail Adresse genannt.
Schreibe dann den eine E-Mail mit der ersten im Anhang was was ich nicht wollte so dass ich bald wieder anfangen was ich will ist folgendes und ich höre nichts und dann kam irgendwann eine Mail dass sie mir in Bearbeitung ist,
und dann kam ein Brief an Einzeiler wir haben alle bei der Schufa löschen lassen.
Immerhin.
Einmal E-Mail.
Warenbrief.
Der Brief kam von.
Von mobilcom-debitel dann dann war noch Anfragen für von Versandunternehmen war noch bei mir drinne gewesen Otto ne.
Also das war eine richtige Reihe.
Richtige Reihe an Sachen Ottos übrigens war auch geil rauszukriegen das habe ich ihm dass ich nicht geschrieben habe meine noch nicht fertig was jetzt,
SR20 erledigt da habe ich dann gewinnst beantragen wegen der Finanzierung ist das wegen Ratenzahlung ich habe halt ich fahre hatte ich kurz vorher Auto Sachen eingekauft,
habe aber Cash bezahlen Vorkasse gemacht hat so okay das ist kaputt dass Satzanfang abend also anzurufen hey leute das ist falsches darf nicht allein.
Und am Ende war es halt dass ich Datenauskunft angefordert habe nach 34 BDSG darauf mit einem Brief geantwortet habe.
Und dann hat mir der Syndikus zurückgeschrieben das ist der Hausanwalt.
Von Otto das wenn es denn so sein sollte so wie ich beschreibe das von Otto das ist Missbrauch gewesen also ganz viel Konjunktive und dieses Schreiben zur Vorlage bei Schufa Rechnung zu löschen.
Zwei Seiten hat eine geschrieben warum nicht schlau bist nicht falsch was ich getan haben.
Einfach nur um seine eigene.
Unbesetzt abzusichern aber zwei Seiten schreiben und ja was darauf gewartet und der Syndikus mit Füller unterschrieben war beeindruckt.
Mama wie lange hast du jetzt damit.
Ich habe angefangen im Januar so zweite Januarwoche glauben I und bin jetzt vor 3 Wochen fertig geworden um den Kram raus zu kriegen.
Bayer.
Ich stell mir gerade vor du bist irgendwie so ein Otto bestell Betrüger oder jemand der Bedarf an mehreren nicht auf Dich registrierten Handys hat ja und.
Von 80 Millionen potentiellen Identitäten suchst du dir ausgerechnet Stephan Urbach.
Seit 10 Jahren mit dem Scheiß auseinandersetzt und länger und die und die stamina hat sowas in in jedem Detail auseinander.
Vor allem wenn dann heute irgendwas hat irgendwie mit dem letzten meinte so ja das ist doch gerade Nachricht an Diana ja Wikipedia Adresse Pflicht.
Name Geburtsdatum Adresse alles was man braucht um sich.
Superland vielen vielen Stellen.
Aber aber schön war das Essen so irgendwie schuldig sagen ich möchte Datenschutz Agro Leute was geht doch mal deine Daten an rum geprügelt habe ich werde so warte ich muss halt.
Also bin ich gelaufen ist.
Katze eine Löschdiskussion an.
Milchwirt relevant.
Ja das wird dieser mit dieser was in der Wikipedia steht das ist tatsächlich irgendwie Problem.
Ja das habe ich auch nie wieder raus aus der Wikipedia und wie sagt Impressumspflicht ich muss Adresse angeben im Regelfall da wo mein Betrieb sitzt das ist bei mir zu Hause wäre sehr ärgerlich.
Ich habe keine Büroräume im Zweifel auch dass wir Büroraum völlig egal weil wir wissen Telefonica die Beträge war nicht an meine Adresse den reicht Name und Geburtsdatum.
Das reicht den um die Anfrage bei der Schufa zu machen und ein jor existiert nicht das Goldberg zurückzuschicken da steht auch nämlich.
Geboren in aber wahrscheinlich oder.
Genau dann.
Jetzt wissen übrigens.
Jan an der Stelle wäre natürlich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll dass man die Schufa quasi dazu zwingt dass man selber diese Einträge auch ab liegt ne.
Ja das sicher auch so leicht.
Komme gleich zu müssen wir da jetzt nicht schon so bei dem Thema.
Nee also ich habe muss ich mitgenommen zu dir noch viel schlimmer alles.
Ja die Sendung darf aber jetzt nicht mehr so lange werden.
Gedichte tut mir leid.
Na dann mal los.
Also Artikel angeschrieben werden und habe dann auch endlich mein Konto klicken können jetzt haben wir rufen Sie an wenn eine Abfrage passiert.
Das probiere ich mal aus lalala kiddyklick tiptip Konto bestellen Persil unser neues Konto mein Telefon.
Dödödö dö dö dö dö dö dö dödödödö.
Ruhe mich Stille auf dem Konto dass ich haben wollte mal einfach an.
Funktioniert nicht o2.
Also machen wir nicht.
Nachrichten III veröffentlicht am plötzlich eine E-Mail vom head of communication der Schufa Holding AG.
Dani.
Gardinen wiederum sofort.
Wenn du mit der super Telefonat führen willst machst du einfach Artikel über die Schufa.
Genau und dann Finger an das ist ja hier Sachen ändern müsste und überhaupt und sage alles gelogen und mich also nicht helfen lassen so nicht mehr,
und dann hat sich geändert haben und überhaupt und ich habe halt bei mir hat's habe ich Haare mit mir telefoniert ne was ich mal angerufen wird minac schicke einfach mal angerufen.
Die sind aber da so das fällt ja auch dass die Schufa offenbar sehr ihre also head of communication der scheint da offenbar die Google Alerts Riegel.
Der ist der Serum.
Der sofort reagiert auf Arne semsrott Aktion damit openschufa Damen sehr sehr schnell reagiert du schreibst ein Artikel jetzt das war jetzt nicht die Frankfurter Allgemeine Sonntagszeitung auf dem Teller.
Das war Golem.
So das Gollum ist jetzt.
Was hilft gegen Golem aber.
Das ist jetzt nicht die FAZ aber da hast du diese sofort eine Hacke oder was und dann und dann zu dir mit rechtlichen Schritten geht.
Ja da hat er erstmal eine Erinnerung für Tiere zu Ende Datum Uhrzeit Platz um den rufe ich an.
Anrufen und 8 mal aufgewacht sie haben E-Mail geschickt.
Akku rausnehmen wieso nicht und dann fängt mit dem erzählen wie wichtig die Schufa ist weil sie ein Verbraucher vor Überschuldung schützt und so und dann werden wir halt nicht.
Sparkasse Bad Homburger ich weiß dass Überschuldung ich jetzt auch passiert war schon wieder schneller dann wissen.
Berlin passiert wenn man sehen kann was für Daten gespeichert sind könnte ich mir aber nicht leisten und will ich mir auch nicht leisten.
Auf jeden Fall haben irgendwie hat nach Punkten verloren.
Ja aber eitrige doch nichts mehr wissen so früh Kreditanfragen Merkmal AKAH sie kennen sich aus habe ich doch gesagt.
Was ist ein.
Arcawa Anfrage Kredit wenn du früher so noch vor ein paar Jahren Kredit haben wolltest hat verglichen bei Instituten großer Fehler jeder Anfang ist gar nicht verschlechtert.
Nein das ist nicht mehr so haben sie geändert von paar Jahren alles war früher so und wenn ich weiß nicht was das noch so ist es stimmt doch jede Handy an Fahrrad Design.
Bin ja geschossen wird es morgen auch nicht ermutigt mich keiner.
Also classic die Sache ist Zuge du fängst an vergleichst Kredite willst was ich irgendwas kaufen Haus oder so und dann werden die Kondition immer schlechter und am Ende der letzte wenn du sagst wenn ich dann für einen entschieden hast sagt er tut mir leid ich kann dir.
Das ist.
Scoring ist irgendwie die letzten zwei Wochen so auf Ramschniveau.
Ist ja nur ich Sollinger Scheiße nicht an dir festhalten paar Fälle V Bank angefangen Haus Creed ging um 301000 € oder.
Am Ende dann für die erste Bank entschieden hat immer schlechte Laune.
Was ist passiert dass das deswegen mussten wir das ja auch ändern auch die Banken sich beschwert haben darüber.
Was hilft denn.
Genau weil wir haben eine Bank angefangen damals andere Anfrage zu machen die hat es doch nicht verändern.
Wir war eigentlich hätten machen dürfen laut Schufa Vertrag als Bank.
Nur die Kunden nicht an den haben neue Kollektion abfragen keine ob wir beide beides noch weiß.
Und immer noch meine Wissens und sind jetzt schon wieder haben muss ja auch nicht.
Was ist das für ein Schutz identitätsschutz ja okay.
Bitte Tierschutz Telefon Klingelton ja wie Warum ist versprochen ich werde angerufen wenn ich wenn das Bild ja nein nein das kann doch sein dass sie angerufen werden ist Joachim Löw.
Was kann sein das kann sein.
Es ist möglich muss aber nicht an.
Seid also das gibt's bei mir auch für 93 Kids bei mir auch.
Oh Gott.
390 eine E-Mail geschickt 390.
Pizza auch oder kann sein.
Batmanda Kriegseinsatz schreiben Sie mit Hallo.
Erinnere alten Daten zu sehen mehr als einmal im Jahr musst du halt in die Geld bezahlen damit ihm helfen kann den Datensatz mit dem sie Geld verdienen.
Wetter zu machen.
Na was sonst immer so welche wie ich und sage hier super aber scheiße Grammatiken drüber Golem und ich war das nicht lange mehr mit mir telefonieren.
Der alles versucht versucht immer noch alles dass die Schufa die Guten sind ja aber ganz ehrlich.
Halten sich ja alle für die gut.
Freitag auch nicht gehört euch euch drüber.
Ich wahrscheinlich auch für die Guten und sehen sozusagen diese ganzen Probleme die Leute haben das hier aus einer anderen Perspektive.
Na ich habe meine auch mal so wissen wo sie und ihre lustigen Schufa scheiße da wir sind nun umziehen mach das noch scary schlechte oder nicht.
Wenn Sie öfter unfaire dresden-weißig address Cory dürfen ich mache aber die Menge der Umzüge ist ja auch noch Spannungsfaktor hat er sich nicht gesagt ich meine Vermutung ist ja aufgrund von scoring konfrontierte umgezogen sind jedoch hinterher ziemlich sagen halt auch gemacht habe.
Bremen Zeiten wo du halt nicht mehr Zink in einer an einem Ort wohnt bei dir nicht bei dem Wohnwagen in den Top Markt.
Und wenn das wie ich bin immer innerhalb von 4 Jahren wecker umgezogen zeitweise.
Ich verstehe gar nicht warum umziehen jetzt überhaupt ein Problem sein soll.
Rectus ja Tresse.
Ja und achso achso man sieht nur um um irgendwie eine neue Adresse zu haben.
Stimmt es ist natürlich nur um um die Schufa.
Vor allem wenn du den familonet Berlin zum ziehst ne so wie ich es auch von mir geht's so Wiki und so und dann kannst du mich aus Zwischenmiete.
Auch ist halt dass ich nicht der Lebensfähigkeit mir was zu Tage also von älteren Menschen die Haus und Hof haben vielleicht schon aber nicht von einer jungen Generation die wo alle sagen soll mobil sein und flexibel.
Das machen doch gar nicht mit den Adressen das ist wie gefährlich rein.
Vermutung zählt also solche Sachen haben ihr wart mal so wissen Sie wie die Einträge dieser Eintrag da wegen wegen der wegen den Stadtwerken das haben uns vor Gericht ja ja,
gibt es etwas abzubilden in der Schufa Schufa Eintrag das ist ein Titel ist wegen dem Vergleich.
Was wir vermissen noch drinne also schicke die du drinne ist auch total richtig hier drinne stehen die habe ich abgelösten Kredit abgelöst drinne Beginndatum und Laufzeit ab wie viel raten.
Da steht nicht drin das.
Schlüssel drinne das lang nicht an das Gemälde Krieg ordentlich bedient wird oder beende das ja aber da ich in der Nacht nach irgendwie 5 der lauf hat abgelöst hatte weil ich werde aber immer noch drinne.
Achso steht aber noch drin.
Gab es jetzt in drei Jahren gelöscht weil fertig ist aber bis dahin wieder drin und niemand weiß ob der noch läuft oder nicht läuft früher beendet es weiß niemand was ich drinne steht.
Okay also wir lernen.
Was ist die Schufa.
Euch eure Schufa Auskünfte schaut rein und guck wie viele Handyverträge ihr habt.
Relevant.
Das nächste Thema.
Da müssen wir nämlich jetzt auch langsam wegen kommen und zwar wurden wir gebeten uns doch mal mit der PSD.
Rei auseinanderzusetzen E-Mail bekommen.
Payment services directive also eine Direktive eine Richtlinie der Europäischen Union die ist jetzt in Version 2 gibt's zum runterladen.
Und dient die regelt die Zahlungsdienste was müssen wir uns genau darunter vorstellen was das ist.
Was ist ein Zahlungsdienst.
Zahlungsdienst Paypal Zahlung mangopay Zahlungsdienst.
Lottemann Zahlungsdienst erstmal generell Menschen die dem Geld hin und herschieben Moderation halt ne das ist weit.
Gefasster Begriff was geht in der PSP subtractive um sich dementieren zwischen danken solchen Sachen wie,
pauli Geldinstitute es geht um auch die den Zwang zur API 5l Banken sind API haben müssen.
Also mittlerweile mit der neuen Version.
Ja also die neue Version kannst du bist jetzt seid ihr Computer geworden da gibt's an.
Aber auch dass es klingt besser als es ist nachher Unvereinbarkeit macht ist dass es erlaubt das Unternehmen gibt.
Das war total sofortueberweisung.de das Problem das finden das wie immer sagen wir geben die PIN ein und dann kann und eigentlich ist Soka nicht erlaubt weil sonst ja nicht hergeben dann die Banken aber.
Und dann Durchfall Abi Zeugnis Möglichkeit das Wort Überweisung de das so machen kann dass meine PIN und TAN wird nicht mehr auftauchen für die API mit meiner Bank kommunizieren dann gibt es es gibt also mehr Kalorien Anzahlung Dienstleistern,
na super da ist Wer streamt einfach nur einen gebe.
Und zwar unterscheiden wir zwischen ich habe hier eine Liste gehabt hatte Spiel verlegt weiß was für ein bisschen blöd bin.
Bitte das noch die falsche auf die falsche ich hab's mir irgend aufgeschrieben gehabt.
Alles geht einmal halt dienen die dann die dein Konto führen halt Nadine API anbieten wann gibt es die nimm denn die mit deinem Konto arbeiten wie z.b. Zahlungs ja sowas wie sofortueberweisung.de.
Und dann gibt's noch so Meret an Anbieter die auf ein Konto zugreifen wäre Bank aggregieren und einem und einem Dashboard.
Beispiel jetzt nur so dass er mal was ich mit meinem Mann i mache auf meinem stationär auf dem Rechner und andere vielleicht im Web haben weil sie nicht mehr was ich mein Telefon haben oder nur an oder halt irgendwie richtig benutzen möchten und können halt das irgendwie aktivieren sollten vielleicht ein Versicherungsdaten mit rein,
Mit sie noch letzten Jahr in Detmold dass er Banken versuchen Sie Ihre Online-Banking Finanzportale für Kunden auszubauen und das liegt,
Wiener psd2 was in Ihren Daten rein spielen können nur dass da darf ist es da.
Kontoinhaber kann dann einen einen Dienst autorisieren meine Daten zu lesen.
H&R für ein auslesen und bei sich verarbeiten so das ist klingt erstmal ganz nett alles ich hatte das schon mal für schwierig weil ich mich nicht.
Klar gibt es da zu trinken und lalala und sie dürfen nur das was ich erlaube I verstehe ich was ich in der Laube Frage 1? Sich dran.
Nenne mir die großen freien sichergestellt und wir reden und fahren will ich will ich dass meine Bank z.b. meine mein Sparkonto bei einer anderen Bank und nach meiner Versicherung alles ein Portal führt.
Die Bank hat sich ja dann kommt doch viel besser gezielt beraten Herr Urbach ich habe doch kein Geld das soll mich da beraten.
Guck mal blöd.
Schuldnerberatung.
Nee das habe ich zu viel dafür habe ich zu viel Geld im 350 plus auf Plus.
Gepard Palmers machte.
Ihre persönliche Armut Verwaltung.
Genau das hat schon da hattest du das soll kein Screen scraping mehr brauchen rein theoretisch das endlich mal Banken jetzt inzwischen auf meinem Online-Banking Zugang gewähren müssen zwei Nächten API Zugang das Dumme ist.
Tut trotzdem weh.
Dann noch nicht müssen bald.
Wann müssen sie denn.
Papaya.
Also gültig ist sie ja offiziell jetzt schon seit 13. Januar.
Ja das macht.
Also es heißt ja nur dass die Richtlinie gültig ist nicht welche Weite.
Feiern in nationale Gesetze um.
Genau das hat noch ein bisschen Zeit alles das alles fertig sein muss eine freue mich ja auch ist dir nicht nur eine API.
Na es gibt Definition marciapie können muss das nennt sich dann xs2a ne access to account.
Das ist nicht fair dass das Meer Definition von von von der Europäischen Union von der EBA European Banking authority was denn da drinne sein muss dieser Stelle.
So jetzt habe ich in diesem Flug die Banken zusammen und dann eine API.
Nee nee nee nee.
Avira momentan haben wir da geht's mir das Open Bank project danke,
dass die Papiere Deutschen Bank es gibt die 5e du hast auch eine eigene also ganz,
viele eigene API sind ganz viel Konsortien dazu die ABS definieren es ist schon so weit dass die ersten Dienstleister da sind im Web die dir anbieten macht bei uns ein abicon wir machen uns alle Banken,
würdest du denn.
Das ist einfacher.
Also wird schon absurd.
Für die sasaya.
Aber haben Sie denn wenigstens dieses Sofortüberweisung mal verboten.
Wie ist das ja jetzt.
Ohne warnhinweis ohne alles.
Da muss ja schon ein es gibt auch zum Outing sie wings.
Dafür dass eine gewisse.
Soll ich definiert ist das auch nicht das muss nur eins geben und okay die psd2 das finde ich sehr gut schreibt ganz neue Wii Party Richtlinien Vorführ incidence.
Institut Klassen eingeführt wo Report werden muss also was wir vor ein paar Jahren Deutsche Bank irgendwen alles doppelt gebucht hatte und dann sag das war nur ein Test habe gelogen haben,
wir Brücke Buchstaben,
das wäre dann musst du auch direkt geboren werden damit mich aber jetzt z.b. dass es jetzt das ist jetzt neu in Anführungszeichen dank der psd2 haben wir den Verbot von Paypal Gebühren.
Das Verbot von Paypal Gebühren.
Ja weil nämlich der PS 472 sehr spannend also indirekt dadurch.
Gibt ja Händler die haben Verschick wie Kartenzahlung Gebühr erhoben.
BBC2 sagt da wo Kunde Bank Bank Kunde involviert es darf keine Gebühr aufgerufen werden Kreditkarte meine Bank deine Bank.
Händler parkhausgebühr aufgerufen werden PayPal ist aber dummerweise ich Bank Kunde oder Händler nehmen.
Das machen was genau sind unsere AGBs will mit ist jetzt PayPal-Gebühren auch verboten weil die PSD halt gesagt hat ja okay also würde.
Also mit Paypal Gebühren sind nicht die Gebühren die PayPal erhebt.
Na dann die die Händler erhoben haben.
Für die Bezahlung mit Paypal keine zusätzlichen Gebühren erheben.
Genau noch bin ich halt auch nicht mehr.
Ja das hat alles das gleiche gilt für den Kunden das ist alles gleich teuer aber man trägt trotzdem natürlich noch gebührend selber kann die sich bloß nicht mehr vom Kunden zurückholen.
Fiat Händler Trage Gebühren trotzdem und ich muss deshalb von Anfang an 1 und reisen.
Tokyo du kannst jetzt keine Pönale dafür vergeben dass du das hier Costa wechsel zu Taxi habe ich das immer kurz ein Euro 5.
Das ist jetzt ist jetzt eigentlich man das muss er ja auch demnächst fallen weil ist eigentlich der psd2 nicht legal.
Freue mich schon auf die Diskussion mit dem Berliner Taxifahrer.
Handelsspanne ist das ist ja ich.
MyTaxi und Sonne.
Aber das wird auch noch sehr spannend und ich glaube das einfach mal eins und Klage.
Das dann auch da weg ist ne das ist auch alles psd2 psd2 ist aber halt auch dass wir jetzt irgendwie lustige lange Dokumente mit Spezifikation haben die nichts bringen weil.
Deshalb momentan ich glaube 6 diskutierte schon was alleine in Deutschland gibt.
Was API betrifft und das halt ich nicht glaube dass allen Menschen Claas was es heißt wenn sie irgendwelchen fintech Simon den ich zur Traube ich sie werfen kann zu mir sein Konto gewährt.
Aber die also gut arbeiten wie eine junge Bank in Berlin die sagt nur Bullshit Ockert.
Kein Fall auch in PS.
Techno Banken ist auch so eine komplette neue Steuer Wolke und so weiter.
Auch das ist alles ganz auch die ganze buchhaltungstool sie halt auch mit dem Konto auslesen direkt einmal ich weiß nicht was ich davon halten soll sie versprechen alle nachher weniger Arbeit ist doch einfach nachher mehr arbeiten raus.
Zumal auf diesen ganzen Verkehrsunternehmen so ist sie noch nicht Buch vorher völlig egal ist tschuldigung.
Würfelregal Designer du bist noch viel besser wie es geht also auch so ein Hippie Bank hier in Berlin die sagt sie also du kannst Film Konto haben also sag und hatte aber nicht mehr haben hatte einfach entfernt gerade oder Firma wenn du Fehler machst kannst ja mit dem Master Karte.
Rechenaufgabe machen deine EC-Karte dein Pirat Aufgaben woher er ist immer das gleiche Konto nee.
Ich halt nicht wer kennt Konten haben soll auf Bank nicht schaffen mehr hat ein Konto einen Kunden zugehen sollten wir von finnische Vornamen verboten werden.
Also Bank ist nicht schafft mehr als ein Konto für mich zu essen weil mein telefon bin nach der Arbeit kann nur ein kommt dran gebunden werden.
Und jetzt vielleicht kann das Mama ein bisschen reduzieren um ein bisschen zusammenfassen also diese PSD Version 2.
Ist jetzt quasi EU-Richtlinien recht damit es ist erstmal noch nirgendswo wirklich gültig.
Dann ist es erst im Moment gültig wie das eben bei EU-Richtlinien so ist wenn es.
In nationale Gesetzgebung überführt worden ist die Fristen Wissmann jetzt gerade nicht auswendig aber das kann halt teilweise ganz schön lange dauern üblicherweise war Großbritannien meistens immer so die ersten die.
Alles was mit Finanzen zu tun hatte umgesetzt haben da kann man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt mehr drauf zählen am so oder so wird sich aber was ändern und du sagst jetzt im Kern.
Abgesehen davon wie es konkret umgesetzt wird sind es ansich schon mal ganz brauchbare Ziele weil es führt ja zu einer Vereinheitlichung auf EU-Ebene.
Genau und halt auch das was ich will auch sinnvoll finden der PSD schönerting Verpflichtung drinne PayPal Luxemburg sitzen im März in Deutschland macht muss sie die muss PayPal die an die Bundesbank melden und an jeder andere,
Nationalbank Zentralbank halt auch das heißt dass auch dann da mal mehr Transparenz in Unternehmen entsteht.
Hast du die Blackbox ein bisschen abgebrochen wird wenn auch nur eine relativen Ebene und nicht auf der jetzt für mich persönlich sind also irgendwie erkennt man Ebene,
incident reporting sind jetzt Länge und Höhe halte ich halte ich für sinnvoll ne das ist irgendwie.
Also Inzidenz im Sinne von.
Da ist ein data breach das irgendwie hier falsch gebucht wann dann Programmfehler habe nämlich Geld falsch geroutet handy auf das jetzt mal Geld überweisen.
Wann muss man nicht.
Da gerade bei der Deutschen Bank wieder passiert.
Ja genau das ist ja wieder passiert in mir.
Ach das ging an Herrn Trump nada.
Ja genau so eine.
Irgendwie nicht vorhersehen.
Na dann sehr spannend ist auch das zwischen screenscraping jetzt zum verboten wird.
Was ist green screen.
Avis aschemann eines Banking Todes benutze die wenigsten Fidor Konto hast sie sagen API ist nicht und dann loggt sich das programm falthintergrund ein und liest den Bildschirminhalt aus und mach dann daraus die Kontoumsätze holt sich das dadurch.
Die trappings einfach das Interpretieren von HTML Eisenmann,
simuliert ein Erbe ist die einzige Möglichkeit teilweise irgendwelche konnten abzufragen hier auch so n26 limbim das kriegst du halt einfach nicht anders.
Deswegen kannst du auch in diesen Onlinebanking tu es halt immer nur auslesen aber in den seltensten Fällen.
Dynaform eine Transaktion darüber starten weil das dann eben doch die Fähigkeiten,
übersteigt oder niemand die entsprechende Verantwortung dafür übernehmen will das ist auch richtig läuft das ist ein grundlegendes Problem und insofern finde ich auch richtig dass jetzt alle zu API ist gezwungen werden,
ja werd ich viel sinnvoller man hätte in dem Zuge auch vielleicht sich mal auf eine API geeinigt oder zumindest auf einen Standardisierungsprozess geeinigt ja dann kannst ja immer noch Unterschiede geben,
frage mich auch warum dann halt sowas wie HBCI und so weiter wenn ich einfach in die nächste Runde gegangen ist.
Wir wissen es nicht auch HBCI wird ja teilweise schon sehr schlecht umgesetzt so.
Zumal dass es für die verschiedenen Module in dieser gibt's ja gibt's ja schon Spezifikation.
Dazu Zweifel ist gibt es gibt eine ist also es nennt sich RTS technisches Tennis und einer ist on strong customer authentication und habe Zwiebel genau das Treffen zum BBS will ich Google neu erfunden zwischendurch,
Parma.
Ja aber der hat ja Deutschland Riesenvorteil gehabt das geht ja noch an.
Ja danke Tasche ist ein draft es kamen in secure communication.
Was ist auch vorgeschrieben das bestimmt beschissen Standards eingehalten werden das weiß eigentlich alles ziemlich gut ist das viel Wildwuchs der vorher da war zwischen Abi.
Das ist weg ist das Mindestalter jetzt eingehalten werden muss.
Ich meine letzten Endes kann ich mir auch ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen dass ich in diesem Markt viele API so halten werden ja dadurch dass alle das dadurch dass alle dazu gezwungen sind Würzmittel mittelfristig nicht kurzfristig.
Mit einer deutschen Bank einen Sparkassen dann einfach nur Open Banking Group dann habe ich vergessen und noch.
Aber es ist Geschosse vielmehr Ausgrenzung durch das nicht anbieten von APIs.
Als durch unterschiedliche ab ist und wenn sie sowieso alle anbieten müssen und wenn sie quasi mit gewissen Mindeststandards auch erfüllen müssen wird es einfach langfristig zu teuer.
Wenn jeder seinen eigenen Protokoll scheiß ewig durchzieht.
Also da habe ich schon Hoffnung das an der Stelle der Markt ein wenig nach Regel auch wenn es jetzt kurzfristig keine Änderung geben wird.
Das ist richtig ich was ich an einem Fenster finde Zeit dass die Regelung auch non-discriminatory Access für Marktteilnehmer verlangt also wenn ich so.
Diskriminieren dazu.
Genau unter Skitour verlangt 100 € für die API.
Dass man die benutzt dass man seinen scheiß Onlinebanking machen kann was ist das für ein Saftladen.
Das musst Du viele Fragen ich habe jetzt nur gerade Takten wiedergegeben ich glaube das wird inzwischen wegfahren müssen.
Ja Tour mit deinem.
Tschuldigung dass ich kacken bringen habe ich eingeladen worden.
H&M verschlossen was heißt das dann die Onlinebanking Tools alle gleichberechtigt auf diese API zugreifen können dürfen müssen können dürfen müssen richtiges Deutsch ich glaube.
Das geht ja auf jeden Fall noch Durchfall haben wir nicht so hohe Maßstäbe.
Na und es gibt halt so also wirklich das will ich nur dass ich dies xs2 Interface Bereitstellung,
wie sieht mein compliant sein als Bank alles weitere ist freiwillig an Kellerwand farbig API Nutzer sein so multibanking scoring werden über scoring was kann man unternehmen auf PS4 zwei Dienstleistung anbieten.
Konto auslesen dann dafür dann der Orthopäden empfehlen die auf jeden Fall darauf in Herzogenrath scheiße ist.
Ja ne das ist das ist echt schwierig und zumal es geht an. Woran ist schon schwer was ohne Schufa zu finanzieren.
Irgendwann ist nicht mehr möglich ohne Kundenkonto was zu finanzieren.
Also von Echsen von Willis alles auslesen ja so dass das ist so mein Problem mit der psd2 also das ist so es geht soweit dass irgendwie ein Markt geschaffen wird der damit ich auch einfach existierten sich bedienen will.
Oder doch Produkt einfach schafft dies vorher auch gehen.
Und ich bin nicht jetzt wie es ist und Einweg Schule an auf keinen Fall aber ich finde es gerade im Finanzbereich echt schwierig wenn da irgendwelche halbseidenen Firmen Zugriffe bekommt man das Kommentare access.
Und kein Marktteilnehmer ausgeschlossen werden nach von der Bank das heißt wenn irgendwie ein Unternehmen windig ist aber gut genug sich darstellt und es schafft das Kunden dann kam eingeben dann tat es das.
Und hatte eine API Zugriff auf das Konto.
Erstmal nur lesen unter Umständen ne vielleicht aber auch schreiben Mama ist es nicht ne Entschuldigung das ist doof da das ist mein Problem.
Das heißt das nächste was was rund Gehen wir sind wieder irgendwelche Twitter teste so ich mache den Krieg auch du hier und gebe deine credentialsid.
Ich bin 47% vegane Einkäufe nach Bio oder irgendwelche blöden.
Ja genau.
Prima können wir schonmal vorberei.
Ja ja es wird wunderschön ja.
Also das ist aber halt das ist halt echt kotzen also ich hab das Aufklärung recht schwierig weiß noch nicht im Leuten das Leben wieder live.
Also die meisten die meisten auf das Leben wieder leichter sind das Gleichnis ich habe nichts zu verbergen wenn ich kein Problem Überwachung haben doch die Kalorien haben eine Sekunde auf diesen mit was ist eine Krankenversicherung auch noch ein paar Tage anbietet über Finanzierung.
Was jetzt könnte und dann sie dass du dann alt dass du Dauerschmerz kaufen ist der Leberwert gerade gut.
Das darf er nicht nach aktueller Stand.
Ja dann fängt er und einen Grund einfällt dein Beitrag zu verändern.
Häuser zufällig korreliert mit Alkoholkonsum die Nachweise von den Kontoauszügen Kneipe Karten 18 Bier.
Also Schnaps Schnaps nur in bar.
Darf nur im Barbier nur fässerweise und auch einfach so also ich habe da Bedenken in diese Richtung geht ich habe jetzt schon Problem mit vielen Dank und treu in mich und ich bin selbst wenn ich weiß ob ich nicht raus.
Gute Gründe ich mich nicht drauf heute.
Trauen sie keinen Unternehmen die solche Leute wie mich jemals beschäftigt haben.
Freiwillig niemand gezwungen und sie habe ich nach der Ausbildung behalten freiwillig.
Schlimm schlimm schlimm.
Der Vater sein eine eine Warnung sein.
Genau übrigens November 2018 SRT müssen die RTS interessiert diese Technik recommendations und dann wahrscheinlich dann also da muss es laufen der Kram habe ich gerade gefunden beim suchen.
Und ja also ich habe nicht gewöhnt.
Dann muss es laufen fliegen November.
Müller 8. November diesen Jahres.
Diese November müssen die APIs laufen.
Du glaubst haltet ihr schon Episoden sind die Plätze hat das Problem die großen backen das war 2017 angefangen fertig zu bauen.
Na gut ich meine müssen annullieren HBCI kam irgendwie upgraden.
Die haben die haben ja echte Abi.
Ja da kann man doch lieber die großen Bank ich soviel Meckern wie man will aber der Rest ist da echt noch nicht hinterher.
Und da kann man vieles Sylvie Investitionspolitik auch nicht hierher aber auf jeden Fall.
Hat gute Ideen gehabt hier ist jetzt wo ich finde es prinzipiell sinnvoll api2 ich hätte mir gewünscht dass die European Banking authority nicht nur sagt was ist können muss man auch Visus können wir uns ja PI definiert.
Zumindest so klare Vorgaben macht dass es relativ Glasbruch hinauslaufen dass der Interoperabilität Druck auch noch höher ist.
Genau das ist.
Weil wenn man nämlich sagt nicht nur ihr müsst eine Empire haben auf die man auch zugreifen muss sein wenn wir uns einfach er sagt mit na ja es muss eine IP geben wo ihr alle aufeinander zugreifen könnt.
Sonoro wecker dann werden Tag später die Interessenverbände am Start gewesen und sehr fein was aus.
Groß und gefährlich aber sofort.
Ja eben dafür ist das alt.
Dann erschließt die PSD Bank Nürnberg hatte schon gebaut hier Leute Argyle tool.
Noch nach Hause komplett automatisiert komplett Creed Auskunft für Banken da also können alle Konten abfragen überall und dann daraufhin entscheiden ob sie mit Kritik geben oder nicht.
Automatisiert komplett durch was die Schufa also macht für Finanzierung momentan in noch extremer.
Übersetze Kunde halt aktiv ja eigentlich eingeben muss und das ist das ganz große Problem.
Hast du bei mir bis hierhin so ein Segway gebaut mich endlich mal was ordentliches was Gutes passiert und jetzt wird's.
Wir wollen zu den Termin.
Es gibt ein scheiß teil ja.
Na super na toll.
Okay ich sehe wir werden dann noch werden das Thema weiter begleiten.
Ja ich denke auch wir werden es auch Begleit.
Viel Spaß.
Aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal zu etwas anders kommen nämlich zu unseren Terminen
Am 11.Mai wie eingangs schon erwähnt Logbuch Netzpolitik 252 bei der gulaschprogrammiernacht in Karlsruhe.
Und am 12.Mai auf demselben Event wie auch schon eingangs erwähnt unser Linus DJ Tellerrock das Haus.
Am 26.05 weiß ich gar nicht ob er schon mal erwähnt alten Logbuch Netzpolitik 256 in Berlin.
Genau und da habt ihr noch die Gelegenheit jetzt blinkt bis zum 7. Mai noch sicherzustellen dass ihr euer lieblings T-Shirt auch gleich auf der Veranstaltung mitnehmen könnt dann muss man nämlich mal ordern und danach können etwas enger werden.
Und vom 8. bis 10. Juni geht die CPU die Chaos Party Ulm.
I Chaos Party Ulm in der Mensa der Uni ist soll ein entspanntes kleines Chaos Event werden mehr Infos findet ihr unter Chaos - Party - ulm.de Vorverkauf ist eröffnet,
und ihr seid natürlich auch herzlich eingeladen euch im Programm einzubringen die Informationen dazu findet ihr auf der Webseite.
Ja damit es in diesem Segment auch beendet und wir kommen endlich zusammen Abschluss und Epilog und haben etwas Danke zu sagen und zwar vor allem an Stefan der sich hier.
Vielfältig eingebracht hat.
Sehr gerne.
Wie immer und du hast auch noch ein paar auf deiner Liste.
Ich habe ohne Clemens und Alexander auf der Liste mit einem herzlichen Dank.
Und ich habe wie immer alle Unterstützer der Metaebene auf der Liste und.
Vielen Dank dafür ihr seid alle ganz toll und wir sehen uns dann bei Logbuch Netzpolitik nur 256 Berlin noch ein paar Ticket zu haben.
Wird langsam eng und ja wir freuen uns darauf den direkten Austausch mit euch.
Bis dahin ciao ciao.
Tschüss.